oui merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Ministre alors avec cet article 5
nous allons parler de la question de la
CVE de la question des impôts de
production et aussi de la question du
lien entre la territorialisation des
impôts et l'action des collectivités
donc dans la version déposée par le
gouvernement nous avons une suppression
de la CVAE pour les entreprises en deux
temps 50% des 2023 les 50% suivants en
2024 pour venir améliorer le
différentiel de compétitivité notamment
avec l'Allemagne et les États-Unis
différentiel que j'ai d'ailleurs dénoncé
lors de la discussion générale donc sur
ce point là nous sommes d'accord avec le
gouvernement par contre nous sommes pas
du tout en accord pour ce qui concerne
les modalités de compensation des
collectivités telles qu'elles sont
prévues par la version du gouvernement
puisque aujourd'hui rien ne nous assure
que la compensation par le versement
d'une fraction de TVA permettra de
garder un lien fort entre les politiques
d'attractivité des collectivités et le
reversement qui sera fait aujourd'hui à
la réforme telle que vous la faites elle
est trop rapide elle n'est pas assez
concertée et en fait pour le dire
autrement on n'a pas envie de revivre la
même chose que la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation et aujourd'hui encore on
aura le temps d'en discuter notamment
quand on étudiera la mission relations
avec les collectivités il y a des
questions qui se posent sur les
potentiels financiers les potentiels
fiscal avec des choses qui ont été mal
appréhendées au moment de la réforme de
la taxe d'habitation qu'il a aussi avait
été trop rapide et pas assez préparé
donc c'est la raison pour lequel rapport
général de manière très juste à proposer
de décaler la réforme alors il nous
semble qu'effectivement et aussi on l'a
je l'ai dit la discussion générale les
aides que vous proposez aux entreprises
pour venir les aider à surmonter la
crise de l'énergie sont faillibles on a
un taux de recours qui est très faible
je pense à l'enveloppe de 3 milliards
ouverts en 2022 qui a été consommé
aujourd'hui à hauteur de 500 millions il
est nécessaire de les aider davantage
notamment quand on voit les différences
d'aide qui sont emportées en Allemagne
aux États-Unis c'est pour ça que le
groupe les républicains dépose un
raisonnement qui vit justement à la fois
envoyer un signal aux entreprises et en
même temps préserver les ressources des
collectivités je ne sais pas si n'auront
l'occasion de le déposer enfin de le
défendre en tout cas c'est le message
que nous souhaitions faire passer la
parole est à Monsieur Lamine
oui merci madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre monsieur le rapporteur
général sur le Président mes chers
collègues quelques mots concernant cet
article 5 qui Rome aussi modestement
dans la continuité de la brillante
intervention de notre collègue Christine
navarrode donc je soutiens toujours
toujours les grandes qualités donc la
suppression de la cotisation sur la
valeur ajoutée des entreprises
il s'agit d'un impôt qui pèse sur la
valeur ajoutée des entreprises dont le
produit est affecté au département et au
bloc communal produit de pour cette
année 2022 de l'ordre de 9,32 milliards
d'euros reversés intégralement donc aux
collectivités territoriales il s'agit
d'un produit territorialisé c'est
important de le souligner sa répartition
reflète réellement l'activité économique
des territoires s'agissant des régions
départ de CVAE affectés a été remplacé
par une fraction de TVA en 2021 le
dispositif proposé
à terme à court terme au moyen terme
suppression sur deux ans de la CV VAE et
suppression complète à partir de 2024
réforme prématurée c'est indiqué par
notre collègue Christine
réforme prématurée en 2023 et avis aussi
sentiment de la commission des finances
remplacement de la CVE par une part de
fiscalité nationale qui diminue encore
le poids des impôts locaux dans les
recettes des collectivités territoriales
néanmoins ce report de la réforme d'un
an pour permettre mettre en place cette
compensation c'est ce qui est aussi
sollicité au total la CVE réversée aux
collectivités en 2023 s'élèverait un peu
plus de 11 milliards d'euros voilà
naturellement je m'adapterai sur les
nombreux amendements et votre est cet
article monsieur le Président Kanner
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre
voici un nouveau mauvais coup qui est
porté aux collectivités territoriales
après la disparition de la taxe
d'habitation nous voici avec celle de la
CVAE
je reprendrai les propos de Monsieur
Olivier Véran porte-parole du
gouvernement le 23 septembre dernier sur
une grande radio périphérique il disait
mais le Gouvernement est favorable à un
dogme le dogme du moins d'impôt le dogme
du moins d'impôt pour certains ça n'a
pas de prix mais en l'occurrence à un
coût et ce coup c'est 8 milliards
d'euros
je pense qu'il faut vraiment s'arrêter
avec ce dogme et il n'est pas question
pour nous monsieur le ministre en tant
que groupe socialiste écologiste
républicain que nous acceptions que
l'impôt payé par des entreprises soit
transférées finalement à tous les
Français qui devront contribuer au
travers de la TVA au financement des
collectivités
territoriales donc c'est une situation
qui est totalement injuste et je vous
cache pas que nous avons vu les
amendements portés par nos collègues de
la droite sénatoriale amendement ou de
reports d'un an avec application au bout
de cette année de la totalité de la
suppression de l'impôt donc ça reste une
suppression de la c.ae ou venir plus
complexe les amendements portés par nos
collègues retaillaux et l'avarede qui
établit un dégrèvement en 2023 comme
moyen de compensation des collectivités
mais au bout du bout il y aura bien la
suppression de la CV
pour ce qui nous concerne nous sommes
clairs dans notre tête claire dans notre
positionnement politique nous ne voulons
pas de cette suppression très clairement
nous pensons qu'il faut des ressources
affectées aux collectivités
territoriales dans le cadre des grands
principes de l'article 72 de la
Constitution et c'est pour ça que nous
porterons un amendement pur et simple
clair et compréhensible de suppression
de cette proposition qui nous semble
particulièrement négative néfaste pour
les collectivités territoriales monsieur
Marie
merci merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre votre suppression
de la CPAE pose à minima trois
difficultés trois questions une question
d'opportunité une question de justice et
une question d'efficacité sur
l'opportunité on peut tout de même
s'interroger si c'est le bon moment de
se passer dès 2023 de 4 milliards
d'euros et de 8 milliards dès 2024 alors
que notre pays est confronté aux
conséquences de la guerre en Ukraine de
l'explosion des prix d'énergie et de
l'inflation qui pénalisent non seulement
nos concitoyens mais aussi bon nombre
d'entreprises est-ce le bon moment au
regard des efforts considérables à
réaliser dans le domaine de la
transition écologique alors que nous
enregistrons l'échec de la COP 27 est-ce
le bon moment au regard de l'état de nos
services publics cette baisse cette
disparition de fiscalité correspondant
par exemple à quatre fois ce que demande
les hôpitaux publics aujourd'hui enfin
est-ce le bon moment on regarde l'état
des finances publiques alors que les
taux d'intérêt augmentent sur le second
point après l'impôt sur la fortune la
flat tax la réduction de l'impôt sur les
sociétés la taxe d'habitation ce sont
près de 400 milliards d'euros de
recettes donc vous avez privé la nation
vous faites un cadeau fiscal
supplémentaire au grandes entreprises
car rappelons-le les TPE et les PME ne
paient pas la ce jusqu'à 500000 euros de
chiffre d'affaires puis 0,25 jusqu'à 3
millions d'euros et vous transférez la
charge du financement des collectivités
sur les ménages qui paient la TVA et
ceci inversement proportionnel à leur
propre richesse enfin une question
d'efficacité en rompant le lien entre
les entreprises et les collectivités
vous placez les mers notamment devant
des choix terribles au moment où nous
mettons en oeuvre le zéro artificiel net
à 0 artificialisation nette des sols
comment amer va-t-il décider
d'accueillir une entreprise alors qu'il
n'aura aucune compensation fiscale sur
celle-ci
face à un projet de lotissement pour
lequel il touchera la taxe foncière
ceci merci
Monsieur Dominati
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre une fois n'est pas coutume pour
ma part je voudrais féliciter le
gouvernement d'avoir tenu un engagement
vis-à-vis du monde économique et des
entreprises et notamment sans les impôts
de production je voudrais féliciter le
rapporteur général qui comme l'a dit
madame lavard a pu souligner
l'inquiétude concernant les
collectivités territoriales mais
néanmoins la nécessité de répondre aux
difficultés que connaissent les
entreprises vous êtes dans une enceinte
monsieur le ministre ou souvent on
défend quand même la dépense publique
mais au seul profit des collectivités
territoriales ils ne viendrait pas à
l'idée de personnes dans cette enceinte
de dire les 5 milliards consacrés pour
le cœur des villes des villes moyennes
il faudrait finalement le reporter d'un
an ou deux ans parce que ça permettrait
à l'économie française d'aller mieux en
réalité je pense que c'est une nécessité
dans le débat qui vous a opposé l'autre
jour
avec le président de la commission des
finances de savoir ce qui de Monsieur
Hollande ou de Monsieur Macron était le
plus favorable en termes de fiscalité
pour l'économie pour ma part je suis de
ceux qui considèrent que au cours du
premier quinquennat il n'y a qu'à une
seule une seule année le sous le
quinquennat de d'Emmanuel Macron on a
été inférieur en prélèvement obligatoire
à celui de François Hollande j'espère
qu'il en sera pas de même pour le second
quinquennat donc pour une fois que vous
faites un effort signification
de bêchement des impôts je vous approuve
monsieur broyer
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues le groupe
écologiste
solidarité territoire tient à dire à
quel point cette baisse cette
suppression de la CVA de la CVAE est une
erreur et même une faute notre pays nous
disiez vous l'autre jour et le plus
attractif pour les entreprises doit-on
être encore plus attractif que plus
attractif vos dogmes deviennent
ingérables il faut à la fois moins
d'impôts et moins de déficits publics
mais vous rajoutez par la suppression de
la CVAE 8 milliards au déficit public
même si vous avez commencé à entendre
que c'était difficile et décider de
l'étaler en deux ans à surprise est plus
grande que dans la majorité sénatoriale
une telle mesure puis cette soutenue et
même si elle est partiellement différée
une grande surprise parce que cette
impôt est un impôt qui lit les
entreprises au territoire et qui par
ailleurs apportent à ces territoires la
recette de nécessaire à leur bon
fonctionnement la compensation par la
c.ae c'est finalement renvoyé sur les
sur les ménages une ressource qui
auparavant pesait sur les entreprises la
TVA est un impôt dont vous le savez
qu'il est socialement injuste il
convient donc de supprimer cette
suppression de rétablir cette impôt qui
n'a pas empêché notre pays d'être le
plus attractif pour les entreprises et
de ne plus affaiblir les collectivités
territoriales c'est une ardente priorité
monsieur alvoldelli
oui merci madame la Présidente sur le
ministre mais mes chers collègues y
compris dans le prolongement d'un
certain nombre d'interventions je veux
dire trois choses
c'est que la c la CVAE est issu de la
taxe professionnelle tout le monde le
sait ici et que ça a été un élément qui
a amené des avantages et on ne verra
tout à l'heure donc dans le débat avec
les amendements c'est classé VAE
contrairement à la taxe professionnelle
a été un rempart contre l'évasion
fiscale
commencait à être un rempart contre
l'évasion fiscale et l'optimisation
fiscale ça c'est la première chose la
deuxième chose c'est que je pense que
notre pays pour qu'il garde son unité et
sa cohésion c'est bien qu'il y a une
territorialisation de la valeur ajoutée
très important parce que sinon on met
les territoires les communes les
départements les régions dans une
concurrence qui s'exerbe au point qu'il
y en a une des communes un des
départements une des régions qui veut
avoir une réponse de monopole certes sur
le terrain de la concurrence mais sur le
terrain d'un monopole et ça c'est pas
bon c'est pas bon pour la cohésion la
troisième chose je voudrais donner une
expérience il y a quelques années avant
que vous ayez voté la loi nôtre j'ai
présidé l'Agence de développement
économique en Val-de-Marne
j'ai fait j'ai sollicité plus de 400
patrons de tout typologie de la petite
TPE au grand groupe je peux vous citer
Ricard Sanofi etc dans mon département à
l'époque l'impôt qui était la taxe
professionnelle qui est devenue la CVAE
dans la préoccupation des patrons du
petit au plus grand patron du point gros
c'était pas la taxe professionnelle
c'était les transports c'était la
sécurité c'était les modes de garde pour
les les salariés de leur entreprise
c'était tout ce qui environne
l'entreprise et ça et ça excusez-moi
c'est ce qu'elle demandait aux
collectivités territoriales donc si on a
le souci de l'entreprise et si on la
soucie du développement économique il
faut pas retirer cette impôt sous
l'autorité des collectivités
territoriales il faut continuer à
territorialiser la valeur ajoutée des
entreprises merci merci il n'y a plus de
demande d'intervention sur cet article
nous en avons passé à l'examen de huit
amendements identiques de suppression
nous commençons par qui défend monsieur
Levy
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre dans la commission monsieur le
rapporteur général cet amendement
demande la suppression tout simplement
de l'article 5 je vais rappeler que le
groupe l'Union centriste n'est pas du
tout opposé par principe à la baisse des
impôts de production mais très
franchement le moment n'est pas du tout
au porteur avec un PLF 2023 qui prévoit
un déficit à 5%, une dette qui atteint 3
milliards d'euros un recours à l'emprunt
de 270 milliards d'euros pour 2023 +
qu'en 2022 et tout ceci repose sur des
données macroéconomiques que nous
acceptons parce que c'est difficile de
les prévoir évidemment mais avec un une
croissance à 1% avec un taux d'intérêt
et une inflation qu'on maîtrise pas du
tout compte tenu de la fragilité et
d'incertitude qui pèse sur le contexte
européen et mondial supprimer cette
impôts de production nous paraît
vraiment
pas la bonne idée pour 2023
moment où on explique à tous les élus
que l'on ne peut pas indexer la DGF
parce que la situation financière du
pays ne le permet pas alors que ça coûte
un peu moins de milliards d'euros et
bien on va se priver d'une recette de 4
milliards d'euros pour cette année et 8
sur 2 ans pour nous très franchement
la baisse de la des impôts de production
et la suppression même pour moitié cette
année de la cbae ne nous paraît pas être
la priorité nationale et je voudrais
ajouter que les entreprises ne sont pas
oubliées en 2023 puisque nous approuvons
l'amortisseur électricité que vous avez
mis en place ça ça nous paraît une
priorité de l'année 2023 qui permettra
aux entreprises lorsque le prix du
mégawatt-heure dépassera 325 euros de
pouvoir bénéficier d'une aide à hauteur
de 50% donc la prise en charge de la
moitié de cette dépense par l'État nous
paraît une aide bien ciblée
utile pour pour aider nos entreprises et
une priorité pour 2023 merci
maintenant monsieur blanc
je
défends en fait l'amendement de madame
mikoulot je considère qu'il est défendu
donc je m'étendrai pas simplement une
observation à l'attention du président
canner c'est un pot qui vient de la en
fait de la taxe professionnelle et en
réalité condamnée depuis 1999 c'est à
dire que depuis strauss-kah en supprime
la part salaire on sait que depuis il
est condamné donc il y a quand même ce
petit rappel historique à faire
aujourd'hui vous voulez le défendre mais
vous l'avez condamné en son temps
n'est-ce pas
merci Monsieur Madame madame Pétrus pour
le suivant
défendu
bien bien
monsieur Cosic merci madame la
Présidente donc le président amendement
déposé au nom du groupe socialiste vise
à supprimer la nouvelle baisse de CVAE
proposé par le gouvernement mépris
d'équilibre des comptes publics et des
besoins de financement de nos politiques
publiques les cadeaux aux entreprises et
aux plus aisés sans contrepartie aucune
ne peuvent plus constituer l'alpha et
l'oméga de la politique économique du
gouvernement d'ailleurs monsieur le
ministre je voudrais aussi revenir sur
la sur la manière dont a été décidé
cette sous pression de de CVAE un simple
coup de feu coup de téléphone donné par
votre Ministre de tutelle la veille de
son intervention le 12 septembre sur LCI
va entériner une décision aussi
importante que la suppression la CVAE
cette décision très verticale n'a
évidemment pas été prise à la suite des
consultations d'associations d'élus et
pour cause elles étaient toutes opposées
à cette suppression
un rebours de ce que vous pouvez
déclarer dans la presse il y a eu un
manque d'écoute de l'ensemble des élus
vous allez argumenter dans votre éponge
j'anticipe que
vous allez assurer la compensation pour
ma part je suis pas convaincu
mais je crois qu'au-delà des logiques
comptables c'est aussi cette mesure
n'est pas uniquement une question de
finance publique en supprimant la CVAE
vous supprimez bien plus qu'une ligne
comptable dans le budget de l'État c'est
une conception de la décentralisation
que vous remettez en cause les mers nous
le disent vous le disent il y a une
nécessité de faire contribuer les
entreprises au financement des services
dont elles et leurs salariés sont
bénéficiaires en supprimant cet article
vous rompez le lien fiscal entre les
collectivités et les administrés mais ce
qui est bien plus dommageable c'est
qu'un sidament c'est le contrat social
qui se voit remis en cause
et c'est ce contrat social qui unit
localement entreprises et territoires et
qui permet de partager un destin commun
local et par cette par cette suppression
c'est ce que vous remettez en cause et
c'est pour ça que nous sollicitons la
suppression de cet article broyé
merci madame la Présidente notre
amendement vise à maintenir la
contribution sur la valeur ajoutée des
entreprises et donc à supprimer cet
article de suppression cette suppression
je l'ai dit est une erreur et même une
faute le contexte économique et les
besoins de financement des services
publics et de la transition écologique
ne permettent pas de renoncer à des
recettes fiscales la COP 27 se termine
elle vient d'annoncer à quel point
l'aggravation du dérèglement climatique
s'accélère et appelle des réponses
nouvelles les entreprises elles-mêmes
ont besoin d'un environnement de qualité
qu'il s'agisse de l'environnement fourni
par l'État dans la formation des
ingénieurs qu'il s'agisse de
l'environnement fourni pour les
collectivités territoriales sous forme
de transport d'environnement social
culturel d'offre de logement pour les
salariés alors affaiblir les
collectivités lorsqu'elles doit faire
face à tant de défi et qu'elles sont en
première ligne pour lutter contre
l'inflation la pauvreté pour développer
accès à l'emploi et la qualité de vie
est une erreur la compensation par la
TVA renverra sur les simples citoyens
une charge supplémentaire et ne
contribuera pas à améliorer le déficit
public de notre pays bien au contraire
il n'y a pas de marge de manœuvre pour
des baisses d'impôts non compensés par
de nouvelles recettes au vu du contexte
budgétaire vous connaissez cette phrase
et celle du premier président de la cour
la fin de l'abondance est pour tous il
n'est donc pas question de supprimer 4
milliards en faveur des entreprises tout
en affaiblissant la transition
écologique la vie des collectivités
territoriales et la capacité de l'État à
faire face à la nécessité de diminuer sa
dette publique notre amendement vise
donc à maintenir la contribution sur la
valeur ajoutée des entreprises
merci de 707 monsieur la ministre vous
merci
monsieur Bocquet
merci Madame on peut pas s'étonner
monsieur le ministre de la réaction des
associations d'élus quand cette annonce
de suppression de la CVE a été faite
s'inscrit dans un processus de
suppression d'impôts locaux depuis
quelques années ça a été rappelé mais où
est votre limite est-ce que la limite
extrême c'est 0 impôt pour le monde
économique c'est une vraie question il
faudrait l'annoncer dans ce cas-là
clairement alors je suis pas toujours un
afficionado de des rapports de la Cour
des comptes même si je reconnais la
qualité du travail que elle mène mais il
faut l'écouter de temps en temps et dans
le rapport qu'elle a présenté à la
commission des finances du Sénat en
octobre dernier elle a dit ceci la
justice fiscale est renforcée à chaque
nouvelle affectation de TVA en
compensation de la disparition d'une
mesure fiscale et je cite en considérant
que la TVA est essentiellement payée par
les ménages les impositions ménage ont
progressé de 19,8% là où la fiscalité
économique a reculé de 31,9% entre 2021
et 2020 donc il va falloir arrêter de
nous parler des finances publiques de la
pression fiscale des ménages ou de tout
autre l'Italie dont vous avez le secret
c'est un transfert de charges clairement
des entreprises vers les ménages et je
voudrais citer monsieur Bouvier
professeur de droit public qui nous
rappelle ceci il n'est pas d'une manière
générale de pouvoir politique autonome
sans pouvoir fiscal merci
merci monsieur le Président Roquier
c'est vous qui défendez le 13-27 de
votre profilé défendu merci quelle est
la ville de la Commission sur ses
amendements
mes chers collègues d'abord je veux vous
saluer toutes et tous parce qu'on va
avoir encore quelques journées et heures
de travail Vous saluez évidemment madame
la présente monsieur le ministre et
chacun puisse exprimer vous connaissez
l'enjeu l'enjeu d'abord il est de dans
ce sujet il y a un enjeu de pour ou
contre une réduction d'impôts qui paie
sur les entreprises deuxièmement à
partir de quelle date au regard du sujet
troisièmement quelle garantie on apporte
aux entreprises aux collectivités pardon
pour qu'il n'y ait pas dans les mêmes
mais même pour les entreprises pour une
raison simple
nous avons un déficit de compétitivité
économique aujourd'hui quand vous
regardez les impôts de production en
2022 c'est 5,6% de la valeur ajoutée des
entreprises nous sommes au-dessus encore
et assez sensiblement en termes de
compétitivité entre les pays en Europe
donc si on allège pas ces impôts nous
restons y compris en sortie de crise et
le plus tôt possible nous serons donc en
plus grande difficulté et on voit avec
les éléments j'ai entendu les éléments
sur l'endettement sur la compétitivité
avec un déficit extérieur du commerce
extérieur qui est pour le moins
préoccupant et donc évidemment nous
continuons de penser qu'il ait besoin
d'alléger les impôts des entreprises
faut-il le faire tout de suite dans les
conditions telles que le gouvernement a
présenté je dis dans les conditions
c'est notamment la condition du
séquençage et de la garantie apporter
aux collectivités pour ne pas revivre le
mauvais film qui tourne au cauchemar de
la suppression de la taxe d'habitation
de notre point de vue non c'est la
raison pour laquelle la Commission a
adopté un amendement pour différer la
prise des faits
de cette suppression de la c.ae afin de
permettre de bâtir un projet juste et
équilibré des compensations je le redis
pour ne pas revivre le remake de la taxe
d'habitation dont on va avoir encore à
connaître dans ce débat les scories qui
perturbent fragments et alimente la
contestation dans nos territoires
donc c'est cet objectif que nous devons
poursuivre ça n'est pas de mon point de
vue l'objectif de supprimer purement et
simplement la CVAE
quelle est la vie du gouvernement
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les sénatrices et sénateurs
nous abordons avec cet article 5 l'un
des débats majeurs de ce projet de loi
de finances qui est celui de la
suppression de la CVE
vous le savez depuis 2017 nous avons
engagé c'est la volonté du Président de
la République une politique visant à
renforcer l'industrie dans notre pays et
essayer d'inverser la tendance que nous
avons connue que notre pays a connu
depuis plusieurs années si ce n'est
plusieurs décennies qui est une tendance
à la désinture des industrialisation la
suppression massive d'emploi industriels
d'usine dans notre pays et notre
conviction c'est que si nous voulons
inverser cette tendance ça passe par une
meilleure compétitivité de notre
industrie et une moindre pression
fiscale sur les entreprises et notamment
sur le secteur de l'industrie dans notre
pays il n'y a pas de miracle si on veut
voir renaître l'industrie dans notre
pays il faut baisser l'impôt qui pèse
sur l'industrie il y a évidemment aussi
des enjeux de formation professionnelle
des enjeux d'apprentissage des enjeux
d'investissement dans des filières
d'avenir et surtout ces sujets là on
pourrait en débattre longuement nous
sommes aussi je le crois au rendez-vous
mais l'enjeu de la compétitivité il est
absolument majeur et on a fait le choix
de s'attaquer à ce sujet
2017 on a eu le débat
ce week-end sur la question de l'impôt
sur les sociétés la trajectoire massive
de baisse d'impôt sur les sociétés que
nous avons accompli ces dernières années
mais les impôts de production c'est un
élément fondamental et majeur c'est la
raison pour laquelle ces dernières
années notamment à l'occasion du plan de
relance nous avons fait le choix
d'engager une baisse massive d'un pot de
production moi je veux rappeler que
quand nous avons engagé cette
trajectoire la France avait un
différentiel d'impôts sur les impôts de
production avec l'Allemagne x 7 fois
plus d'impôts de production en France
qu'en Allemagne quand vous êtes un grand
groupe industriel ou pas que vous avez à
choisir du lieu où vous allez implanter
une nouvelle activité que vous hésitez
entre deux pays qui se touchent et que
vous en avez un qui taxe 7 fois plus la
production que l'autre évidemment
évidemment que ça rentre en compte dans
le choix que vous faites et que ça a
pénalisé l'industrie de notre pays
pendant des années donc nous avons fait
le choix de baisser massivement ses
impôts de production nous avons supprimé
la CVAE région compensée par une
fraction de TVA et je n'entends pas
aujourd'hui les régions regrettaient ce
choix surtout avec la TVA extrêmement
dynamique que nous avons connue cette
année un surcroît de recette qui est
bien supérieur à ce qu'elles avaient
anticipé bien supérieur à ce que ça
aurait été si la CVE était encore en
place pour les régions nous avons un
plafonné la valeur ajoutée et nous avons
divisé par deux la CFE et la TFPB pour
les établissements industriels tout ça
fait une baisse de 10 milliards d'euros
10 milliards d'euros après cette baisse
de 10 milliards d'euros nous sommes
toujours dans un différentiel massif
avec le reste des pays européens je vous
donne un chiffre les impôts de
production en France sont toujours deux
fois plus élevés que la moyenne de la
zone euro deux fois plus élevé ces 3,1%
du PIB en France entre 1,5% du PIB en
moyenne dans la zone euro et nous sommes
toujours quatre fois plus élevés que les
Allemands 3,1% du PIB en France contre
0,7 du PIB en Allemagne donc il y a
toujours ce différentiel massif c'est la
raison pour laquelle il faut poursuivre
dans la baisse des impôts de production
et c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
proposons la suppression de la CVAE dans
ce PLF nous la proposons et nous
l'assumons d'autant plus quel
bénéficiera je le redis massivement et
prioritairement à l'industrie la
suppression de la CVAE elle bénéficiera
à 530 000 entreprises l'industrie sera
le premier bénéficiaire 25% des gains
iront au secteur industriel c'est deux
fois la part du secteur de l'industrie
dans le PIB
dire que l'industrie bénéficiera deux
fois plus de la suppression de la CVE
que ce qu'elle représente dans le PIB
aujourd'hui elle bénéficiera d'abord au
PME et aux ETI 75% du gain vont pour des
iront pour des PME et des ETI c'est 32%
pour les PME 41% pour les ETI
une ETI industrielle je donne un exemple
qui réalise 30 millions d'euros de
valeur ajoutée pour un chiffre
d'affaires de 80 millions d'euros verrez
ainsi une baisse d'impôt annuel de
225000 euros donc oui c'est une mesure
de soutien à notre industrie à un moment
notre industrie on a vraiment besoin je
m'exprimais il y a un instant sur la
question du différentiel entre les
impôts de production en France et en
Allemagne et la différence avec la zone
euro ce qui a motivé notre trajectoire
et notre volonté de baisser les impôts
de production ces dernières années je
dirais que ces dernières semaines ces
derniers mois nous avons des raisons
encore supplémentaires de nous engager
et de poursuivre dans cette voie puisque
au-delà de la compétition entre la
France et ses voisins européens pour
attirer des activités et notamment des
activités industrielles nous faisons
face désormais à une compétition encore
plus forte avec les États-Unis
on a changé de monde quand on parle de
ces sujets là depuis que les Américains
ont sorti leur inflation Redemption
actes lira avec des crédits d'impôts
massifs massifs pour le secteur
industriel en matière d'énergie et en
matière de technologie d'avenir si on
veut que l'Europe si on veut que la
France reste compétitive si on veut non
seulement attirer des investissements
mais éviter que les investissements qui
ont été réalisés en France s'en aille
pour aller aux États-Unis il faut
poursuivre dans la voie de la baisse des
impôts de production sinon le chemin qui
a été fait ces dernières années encore
une fois qui est un chemin je ne dis pas
qu'on a effacé des décennies de
désindustrialisation dans notre pays
mais quand même depuis désormais trois
ans il y a plus d'usines qui ouvrent que
d'usine qui ferment il y a plus d'emploi
industriels qui sont créés que d'emploi
industriels qui sont détruits c'est bien
que cette politique elle porte ses
fruits et les estimations dont nous
disposons de la direction générale du
Trésor sur la suppression de la CVE
proposée dans ce projet de loi estime
qu'elles permettra d'obtenir 0,7 points
de PIB en plus 120 000 emplois directs
en plus dans dans les années à venir
dont 57000 des 2025 ce sont les
estimations réalisées par la DG trésor
donc moi j'appelle vraiment à un vote en
faveur de l'industrie française de
l'industrie européenne un vote pour
l'emploi pour l'activité économique dans
notre pays et je le dis pour les
recettes des finances publiques incinées
puisque plus il y aura d'activités
économiques dans notre pays plus on
arrivera à développer l'industrie à
développer l'emploi dans notre pays plus
on bénéficiera de recettes pour financer
nos politiques publiques
merci avant de donner la parole au
président rénal je vous informe qu'à
l'issue des explications de vote il y
aura un scrutin public sur tous ces
amendements identiques monsieur le
Président rénal vous avez la parole
monsieur le Président rénal
oui mes chers collègues on est
évidemment sur un dossier important et
pour ma part un dossier sur lequel je
suis négatif depuis le début on va au
moins parler de constance dans la
position
beaucoup d'éléments ont été donnés moi
je voudrais revenir sur quelques-uns
d'abord je n'aime pas beaucoup le débat
sur ceux qui sont pour la compétitivité
des entreprises ceux qui sont contre la
compétitivité des entreprises à pas de
sens on est tous favorables à la
compétitivité de l'industrie française
bien entendu de manière générale da
n'est pas le sujet un sujet moral ou un
sujet de dire il y aurait un débat pour
les entreprises pour entreprises un
débat contre les entreprises ce n'est
pas vrai
la question de la compétitivité
aujourd'hui c'est pas la compétitivité
sur quelques
milliers d'euros centaines de milliers
d'euros pour les grandes entreprises sur
la CV je ne le crois pas et si
d'ailleurs c'était le cas on ne serait
pas aujourd'hui le pays et vous le
revendiquez depuis longtemps qui attire
le plus les investissements
internationaux en Europe donc premier
point ça viendrait ces contradictoires
de dire qu'on est les premiers et en
même temps qu'il faudrait faire encore
plus etc de manière immédiate dans le
temps on peut regarder les choses mais
de manière immédiate donc cette question
de compétitivité aujourd'hui c'est le
prix de l'énergie par exemple ça oui
c'est un vrai sujet et plutôt que de
distribuer largamanu sur l'ensemble des
entreprises mieux vaudrait cibler les
aides là où il y en a besoin aujourd'hui
pour l'industrie c'est-à-dire sur le
prix de l'énergie et quand on aura réglé
cette question déjà on peut voir
beaucoup plus loin ensuite report ou
suppression évidemment suppression bien
que le report
excusez-moi mes chers collègues mais bon
c'est une technique pour maintenir
maintenir le chou les navets le truc bon
on est pour on est pour l'entreprise et
en même temps on souhaite que les
collectivités on souhaite surtout passer
les élections sénatoriales à venir voilà
c'est ça le sujet et moi je crois et je
crois sincèrement qu'il faut arrêter
avec cela je reprends de la parole sur
d'autres sujets tout à l'heure
monsieur Lemoine
en explication de vote effectivement sur
ces amendements qui proposent de
supprimer l'article 5 nous sommes
attachés à cet article 5 au groupe RDPI
parce que nous souhaitons concilier
effectivement et bien cette
compétitivité de nos entreprises avec
également les moyens affectés aux
collectivités locales c'est cette
semaine on le sait le Congrès des Maires
de France c'est également cette semaine
la Semaine de l'Industrie et nous
voulons et bien que les uns comme les
autres puissent bien se porter donc cet
article il prévoit un certain nombre de
garanties je pense notamment au Fond
national d'attractivité qui permettra
sur la part qui n'est pas la pare socle
mais la part liée à la dynamique
nationale de la TVA et bien de conserver
une forme de lien avec les territoires
et peut-être dans le courant du débat
monsieur le ministre pourra d'ailleurs
rassurer sur cette dimension là puisque
ça a été au cœur des interventions de
plusieurs d'entre vous mais on ne peut
pas verser des larmes de crocodile à
chaque fermeture d'usine sans prendre le
taureau par les cornes pardonnez-moi
cette expression
familière mais beaucoup a été fait déjà
depuis
cinq ans et même un peu avant il faut le
reconnaître mais nous avons besoin de
pérenniser cette avantage comparatif qui
a permis de relocaliser des emplois de
relocaliser des industries et je veux
dire d'ailleurs que
un peu dommage un peu triste de voir que
certains programmes présidentiels qui
ont été présentés sur d'autres bancs
manifestement sont où sont les sens
programmées puisque la baisse des impôts
de production a été assez largement
partagée par de nombreux candidats à
l'élection présidentielle et aujourd'hui
on voit et bien une forme de de
reniement en voulant supprimer cette
article justement qui baisse ses impôts
de production et donc pour toutes ces
raisons et bien ne nous opposerons à la
suppression de l'article madame la
Présidente merci la parole à Monsieur
Ferro
merci madame la Présidente chers
collègues à ce débat ce matin sur
certainement l'un des articles les plus
importants du PLF je dirais que la
suppression de la CVE elle a 3 défauts
d'une part montre bien que la politique
de compétitivité la politique de l'offre
du gouvernement elle se fonde sur une
concurrence du moins 10 ans fiscal qui a
vocation a toujours se poursuivre et qui
est une baisse des impôts comme un puits
des impôts de production comme un puits
sans fond ou ça va s'arrêter ensuite et
il faut aussi le dire c'est un transfert
de fiscalité des entreprises sur les
Français et d'abord sur les Français les
plus modestes puisque la compensation se
fera par une fraction de TVA et la TVA
elle elle est d'abord payée par les
Français qui consomment la plus grande
part de leurs revenus et par ailleurs
alors qu'on a déjà réalisé la même chose
pour remplacer la redevance télé que
va-t-il rester à l'état des recettes de
TVA dont on sait qu'elles sont
extrêmement importantes et puis enfin
cette une remise en cause progressive de
ce qui font de la décentralisation
c'est-à-dire l'autonomie fiscale le lien
entre collectivités leur territoire et
comme le disait
Eric Bocquet les fonts qui est au
fondement de la démocratie locale donc
plutôt que de créer une usine à gaz
plutôt que de reculer avant les
sénatoriales pour mieux sauter après les
sénatoriales comme le disait le
président de la commission des finances
je pense que nous devrions aujourd'hui
faire simple supprimer cet article et je
pense que les maires qui sont en congrès
cette semaine il serait extrêmement
sensible
la parole est au président de la
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre bonjour à tous bonjour au
rapporteur général je salue aussi tous
les amis ici présent comme l'a fait le
rapporteur général
nous allons voter cette suppression de
la suppression de la CVAE pour pas mal
de raisons le président rénal on a
repris un certain nombre dont je vais
pas les reprendre mais
d'abord nous sommes favorables à la
baisse des impôts d'une façon générale
mais simplement elle doit être le
corollaire d'une baisse de la dépense
publique sinon c'est du pipeau quand on
pèse des impôts et qu'on augmente les
déficit et la dette en fait on reporte
tout ça sur les générations futures on
ne fait pas les efforts et donc pour
nous c'est déjà pas bon en soi
deuxièmement à chaque fois qu'on baisse
des impôts on l'a vu avec la taxe
d'habitation 20 milliards là c'est 8
milliards sur la CVAE ça se fait au
détriment des collectivités locales et
nous sommes pour l'autonomie fiscale des
collectivités locales et là on est en
train d'affaiblir progressivement et je
vous annonce la suivante la suivante ça
va être la taxe foncière sur les
entreprises
la taxe foncière bâtie sur les
entreprises ou si on a plus que ça avec
les particuliers les propriétaires on va
avoir cela donc nous nous sommes pas
favorables à cette déshabillage en fait
fiscal des collectivités locales et en
plus les conditions effectivement de la
compensation ne sont pas bien déterminés
aujourd'hui donc on peut toujours les
reporter à de vitam en se disant tiens
on va reporter un petit peu et on se
dira ça sera mieux après moi j'aimerais
qu'on ait la clarté sur le sujet dès
maintenant donc comme on n'a pas de
clarté aujourd'hui on n'a pas de
visibilité pour les collectivités
locales on leur supprime de l'autonomie
et ensuite on affaiblit notre pays sur
le plan budgétaire donc nous sommes pas
favorables à cette suppression donc nous
demanderons la suppression de la
suppression
merci la parole est au président
carouchi
[Musique]
créer une situation absolument
hallucinante et moi je autant je
comprends l'intérêt de baisser les
impôts de production autant monsieur le
ministre je partage la vie du rapporteur
général il faut au moins que ce soit
bien fait quoi parce que le côté
suppression de la redevance
audiovisuelle on sait pas comment la
compense au dernier moment vous on nous
dit une part de TVA mais ça n'est
possible que pendant deux ans donc dans
deux ans on recommence le débat de la
compensation parce qu'on n'a pas tout ça
fait quand même un petit peu comment
dire un petit peu un petit peu passé
ailleurs quoi donc moi je partage
l'opinion du rapporteur général il faut
qu'on ait un délai pour travailler
sereinement et si vous pouviez monsieur
le ministre reprendre non pas
l'engagement de Jean-Marc Ayrault mais
presque Jean-Marc ayant en 2013 nous
disait ici même il faut remettre à plat
l'ensemble de la fiscalité je prends
l'engagement qui n'a pas été tenu mais
je prends l'engagement d'assises de la
fiscalité pour remettre à plat les
ressources des collectivités locales des
entreprises de l'État il est grand temps
qu'on est un peu plus de visibilité sur
tout ça si Madame Lavarde
oui merci madame la Présidente alors il
va y avoir un scrutin public ce sera pas
une surprise le groupe des Républicains
va s'opposer à la suppression de
l'article pour les raisons que j'ai
expliqué tout à l'heure parce
qu'aujourd'hui il nous semble
qu'effectivement les entreprises elles
ont besoin d'être soutenu dans un
contexte où elles font face à des
charges qui explosent et je pense que
tout ici nous voulons que l'emploi soit
préservé que notre pays continue à
produire de la richesse ou dans
l'article du gouvernement et je l'ai
déjà dit nous avons un véritable
problème qui est celui des modalités de
compensation pour les collectivités ça a
été redit par le président de La Haye on
n'a pas eu de simulation on n'a pas de
on a rien on nous demande en fait de
croire la bonne parole du gouvernement
qui nous dit la tvae va être affectée de
avec de la territorialisation les
collectivités qui ont investi pour
attirer des entreprises seront
récompensées de leurs efforts mais
aujourd'hui on est vraiment enfin ces
chats échaudés craint l'eau froide
franchement la taxe d'habitation ça nous
laisse vraiment très circonspect sur
tout ce qui peut advenir aujourd'hui sur
les modalités de compensation quand
elles sont pas
séparer et concerté avec un peu plus que
le mois qui a séparé le la présentation
du PLF le 26 septembre et les débats
dans les hémicycles alors c'est vraiment
enfin juste je veux dire ici que si on
vote la suppression de cet article on ne
pourra pas discuter des amendements qui
visent à proposer une autre réforme
l'autre réforme c'est soit l'amendement
de Monsieur Retailleau qui vise à
transformer la compensation de TVA par
un dégrèvement qui la permettrait pour
les entreprises de ne pas payer 50% de
leur CV à eux l'année prochaine et pour
les collectivités pendant deux années
complémentaires d'avoir un reversement
de CVAE comme si rien n'avait changé
dans le paysage fiscal et ensuite dans
le grand j'ai une réforme ou
l'amendement du rapporteur général qui
demande de décaler la réforme d'un an de
manière à ce qu'elle soit préparée donc
il y a des dispositions alternatives il
me semble à l'article 5 donc il faut
qu'on en est tous conscience au moment
où on va voter peut-être ou pas sa
suppression madame paoligaja
oui madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues
je ne voterai pas pour cet amendement je
suis favorable à la suppression de la
CVAE c'est un mauvais impôt c'est un
mauvais impôt à double titre il est
assis sur le chiffre d'affaires et non
pas sur le bénéfice il pénalise le plus
les entreprises qui ont des marges
brutes faibles notamment les entreprises
industrielles donc je crois davantage à
la création de richesse par la
réindustrialisation de nos territoires
et je pense qu'il faut qu'il y ait une
compensation territorialisée dynamique
via la TVA j'ai souhaité aussi faire un
petit rappel historique en disant que
trois groupes parlementaires qui se
reconnaîtront lors de la discussion du
projet de loi de finances 2021 ont voté
pour une baisse massive de cette même
CVAE
merci Monsieur Languet
oui madame la présidence monsieur Luis
mes chers collègues la suppression sèche
de l'article 5 n'est pas acceptable
parce que ce serait un signal
négatif adressé aux entreprises qui ont
besoin d'avoir la certitude que les
impôts de production vont évoluer et
vont pouvoir
alléger ceux qui ont l'effort de
l'investissement le risque de l'emploi
le risque de l'environnement les
entreprises ont besoin de savoir en
effet que ces impôts de production vont
évoluer mais les collectivités locales
ont le droit tout autant de savoir
quelle sera la récompense de leurs
efforts
j'ai présidé la région Lorraine pendant
12 ans nous avons eu des investissements
étrangers d'une façon constante
jusqu'aux lois de Madame AUBRY mettant
en œuvre le projet des 35 heures
les collectivités locales se sont
battues pour retrouver de l'attractivité
elle se battent pour faire en sorte que
les viabilités les réseaux les
infrastructures les les zones d'activité
souhaitent attractives évidemment les
exigences des industriels et des
investisseurs modernes sont aujourd'hui
beaucoup plus élevés il faut qu'il y ait
un lien entre l'effort d'attractivité
des collectivités locales pour
accueillir des investissements et le
bénéfice qu'elles ont retournent or ce
lien risque de disparaître je rappelle
que la CVAE et l'enfant de la commission
des finances du Sénat lorsque Madame la
et voyez c'est un précédent tout à fait
honorable c'est en rendu compte que la
suppression de la taxe professionnelle
annoncée par le président Sarkozy mais
préparé par personne était une véritable
catastrophe pour les collectivités
locales madame Lagarde a eu
l'intelligence de dire bah si vous avez
des idées supérieures
développer les et c'est exactement ce
que vous demande monsieur le ministre
nous ne voulons pas de la suppression
sèche nous voulons d'un temps de
réflexion mais une indication sur la
volonté du Parlement merci à part les
amis
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre dans l'esprit de ce qu'a dit le
président rénal et d'autres pas de
moralisation du débat ici dans
l'hémicycle on n'est pas sur un
référendum pour ou contre l'économie
pour ou contre le développement
industriel de notre pays ça ça marche
pas on n'aura pas une discussion binaire
comme ça la deuxième chose c'est que là
je voudrais m'adresser à mes collègues
les républicains qui viennent nous
expliquer leur vote excusez-moi monsieur
le rapporteur général et mes collègues
républicains et vous parlez de la taxe
d'habitation et vous avez pas de mémoire
vous avez voté ça suppression et vous
saviez 30% des gens les plus modestes ne
la payaient déjà pas donc assumez les
gérer vos contradictions vous avez juste
eu un débat de calendrier et là vous
allez leur faire la même chose vous êtes
pour la TVA évidemment avec un moment un
amendement qui va arriver en disant bah
on va faire un dégrèvement à 50 % etc ça
c'est de la politique politique hard
franchement quand on a pas de Digne ou
alors quand on veut gouverner si vous
voulez gouverner avec le gouvernement
vous gouvernez avec le gouvernement mais
vous assumez vous assumez vos positions
et pourquoi il y a un problème parce que
quand même la CVAE je fais un rappel ici
qui est comme important pour nos
collectivités territoriales j'ai regardé
en 2018 c'était 22 milliards
on est passé maintenant on va discuter
de 8 milliards
donc c'est pas une affaire de bricolage
la faire c'est un désengagement de la
part de la valeur ajoutée pour les
territoires donc pour les collectivités
territoriales c'est pour ça qu'on
demande la suppression et je m'excuse
monsieur le ministre et mes chers
collègues l'État et les communes c'est
la même chose Monsieur le Ministre
l'État et les communes c'est la même
chose c'est une entité voilà donc on
peut pas déshabiller Paul pour habiller
Jacques parce qu'à la fin c'est la
République et la démocratie qui recule
et y compris les services publics donc
on peut pas nous faire un jeu comme ça
d'écriture et de bonbons de ce point de
vue là alors la suppression mes chers
collègues je pense pas qu'on va vous
convaincre de changer de vote mais de
clarté politique d'esprit de
responsabilité la suppression c'est un
report clair et ça permet au
parlementaire aussi bien au Sénat de
continuer à travailler sur son contenu
de l'améliorer voilà avec la menace en
plus du 49-3 qu'on a encore en ligne de
vie donc vous savez que je déteste
vraiment vous coupez la parole donc
soyez gentil interrompez-vous quand vous
avez fini votre temps de parole ne
m'obligez pas à le faire la parole est
maintenant monsieur brouillé
je vais tenter madame la Présidente par
respect pour votre fonction 50 milliards
d'intérêts de la dette + 14 par rapport
à l'ancien si j'étais libéral je dirais
c'est vraiment pas le moment de
supprimer 4 milliards de recettes pour
l'État
mais ça n'a pas l'air de déranger
finalement les rangs de la majorité
sénatoriale se débat sur le déficit
public saute au moment où on parle de la
CVA si c'est pour défendre l'industrie
effectivement tous les collègues l'ont
dit nous voulons aussi de l'industrie
mais j'ai entendu il y a deux jours le
ministre nous dire que nous sommes les
premiers en Europe les plus attractifs
et donc il faudrait être plus attractif
que plus attractif mais j'aimerais qu'on
parle chers collègues des collectivités
territoriales j'ai été élu ma mère
j'avais la taxe d'habitation la taxe
professionnelle j'ai développé dans ma
commune l'arrivée de nombreuses
entreprises ça permet de financer des
politiques sociales et c'est ce qu'on
est en train de retirer à tous nos
collègues maires nous leur retirons leur
autonomie fiscal vous le savez
parfaitement il faut laisser au
collectivités des recettes par ailleurs
retirer au collectivités des recettes
pour faire peser les dépenses sur les
citoyens ça n'est vraiment pas
raisonnable mais je voudrais dire un mot
quand même encore sur les collectivités
on peut pas parler de la suppression
[Musique]
merci Madame à la présidente monsieur le
ministre alors nous sommes évidemment
pour la suppression des impôts de
production et pour le monde de
l'entreprise cela va de soi mais
permettez-moi aussi de livrer une
réflexion sur effectivement la
décentralisation pourquoi ce pays n'aime
pas sa décentralisation pourquoi n'aime
pas il n'a pas aussi sa libre
administration sans laquelle
tu ne peux pas exister sans autonomie
financière il n'y a pas d'automie
financière sans impôts locaux propres
voilà et là bel et bien c'est la
suppression définitive de la fiscalité
locale voilà vous citez notre collègue
site le professeur Bouvier je le citerai
également nouvelle compétences nouveau
financement il y a bien des nouvelles
compétences qui va falloir financer pour
les collectivités locales qui n'ont rien
à voir avec avec l'État et parmi ces
nouvelles compétences il y a celle
tirées de la loi climat j'en citerai
qu'une sur le financement du zan qui met
légèrement en ébullition tout nos
territoires voilà quel financement
allons-nous trouver pour ces nouvelles
compétences voilà on dontact nous
demandons du temps et dans le
prolongement de mon collègue je pense
qu'il est vraiment temps de remettre à
plat cette fiscalité locale on ne fait
que l'annoncer depuis 20 ans ne le fait
jamais et c'est pour ça que nous
demandons du temps mais oui quand même
pour nous un jour nous poser la question
de savoir si nous voulons vraiment une
décentralisation vraiment une libre
administration vraiment une autonomie
financière vraiment des impôts locaux
propres juges juste pardon et qui serait
utile pour financer les nouvelles
compétences à venir
la présidente Christine lavard de la
rappeler nous sommes sur un problème de
fond supprimer ou pas la CVAE
c'est-à-dire accepter le désarmement
fiscal de l'État ou pas et par la même
faire porter encore aux collectivités
tous les efforts notre discussion ça a
été rappelé aussi pose bien le le
problème des finances locales et du
nécessaire équilibre entre recettes
fiscales et dotation de péréquation mais
avant de supprimer une recette telle que
la CVAE étant donné l'ampleur des
conséquences que cela peut avoir il me
semble qu'on a mis un petit peu la
charrue et avant les boeufs et là on
tape
on tape encore sur les collectivités
sans une réflexion d'ensemble bientôt si
on continue comme ça il y aura plus il y
aura plus grand chose à quoi à quoi
réfléchir les collectivités seront trop
mal en point
monsieur Bocquet oui merci madame la
Présidente intervention assez courte qui
vaudra défense du 844 donc vous voyez je
pense qu'au niveau temps vous serez
gagnant nous serons gagnants monsieur
Macron est venu à Toyota à onnain en
janvier 2018 parce qu'à l'époque la
direction Toyota avait annoncé
l'investissement de 400 millions d'euros
dans le site de Toyota onnain
indépendamment de la CVAE qui existait
d'ailleurs et si on remonte à l'origine
du choix d'implantation de Valenciennois
97 je crois à l'époque le site était en
concurrence avec l'Angleterre l'Irlande
la Pologne je crois les Pays-Bas et
c'est ce site qui a été choisi à
l'époque la taxe professionnelle a
existait ça n'a pas été du tout
dissuasif pour le choix de l'entreprise
parce que il y a de la méthode qualifiée
sur place il y a des jeunes qualifiés
parce que les salaires dans la
métallurgie sont faibles
bien sûr que c'est un paramètre de choix
parce qu'il y a un réseau routier parce
qu'il y a une situation géographique
importante à côté du Benelux du
Royaume-Uni il existe en du tunnel les
grandes régions industrielles du nord de
l'Europe
l'électricité l'électricité à l'époque
était la moins chère d'Europe c'est en
train de changer c'était aussi un choix
d'implantation vous voyez donc c'est en
supprimant des impôts comme vous le
faites que vous aggravez la dette que
d'aucun condamne ici régulièrement donc
il faut aussi arrêter d'opposer
collectivités et entreprises
effectivement tout ça c'est un
écosystème et tous les investissements
que les collectivités réalisent sur les
territoires ça contribue à améliorer le
cadre de vie pour les entreprises y
compris leurs salariés voilà merci
Monsieur bacheler
merci madame la Présidente chez le
ministre mes chers collègues d'abord je
voudrais rétablir une vérité monsieur
salvadelli c'est que nous avions voté et
c'est la cohérence de l'amendement de la
commission proposée par Jean-François
Husson que je soutiens
de reporter cette suppression pourquoi
car nous ne voulons pas ici je pense
dans notre très large majorité supprimer
de l'autonomie fiscale au collectivité
alors avant de supprimer sèchement comme
c'est certainement proposé par
le ministre et pour répondre aux
injonctions de l'élection présidentielle
qui n'a pas trouvé de légitimité dans
l'élection législative il faut le
rappeler
on a supprimé la redevance là on veut
supprimer de manière sans avoir résolu
les problèmes et d'ailleurs on le résout
pas Roger caoutchi il a déjà largement
expliqué dans cette hémicycle on fait la
même chose sur la CVE on supprime
sèchement on n'a pas le mécanisme propre
de compensation aux collectivités
locales
nous sommes pour la suppression des
impôts de production mais il faut
trouver un autre impôt local il faut
donc y trouver quelque chose pour garder
de l'autonomie car à force c'est certain
et je comprends le dessin du président
de la République qui veut qu'il n'y ait
ni droite ni gauche
mais dans une élection locale augmenter
les impôts comme à Paris c'est un choix
ne pas les augmenter c'est un autre
choix et donc il faut pouvoir aussi
assumer de la cohérence politique et
c'est à cela que j'appelle donc
aujourd'hui il faut trouver des
mécanismes locaux pour que les apôts
locaux puissent être perdurer et il ne
faut pas envoyer des signaux négatifs
aux entreprises sur évidemment les
impôts de production et j'en termine à
10 secondes même la présidente merci
Monsieur Brisson
Présidente je vais peut-être répéter ce
qu'on dit mes collègues voilà peu mais
j'ai envie de faire parce que je trouve
que la manière tourne la position du
Google République avec critiqué et quand
même assez politicienne et finalement
fait penser que nous trouvons au bon
équilibre entre notre volonté c'est
notre droit de vouloir supprimer un
impôts de production et cela a été
parfaitement argumenté que l'on ne soit
pas d'accord sur d'autres pans de
l'hémicycle sur la suppression d'un
impôts de production cela n'est pas
nouveau mais nous réaffirmons notre
volonté mais nous souhaitons comme la
très bien dire Roger caoutchi prendre du
temps parce que nous sommes échaudés par
bien des précipitations qui ont entraîné
des situations complexes pour les
collectivités donc je crois que nous
sommes dans le bon équilibre nous
affirmons un principe celui de la
suppression d'un impôt de production et
nous demandons gouvernement d'où le sang
c'est l'intérêt de l'amendement du
rapporteur général et de Bruno
Retailleau d'amonter l'art sans le
supprimer pour donner aux collectivités
une visibilité dont elles ont besoin et
pour dire clairement et notamment que
nous voulons un système alternatif qui
ne les laisse pas excusez moi de
défendre une opposition d'équilibre qui
est celle de groupe et de repousser des
attaques que j'ai trouvé trop
moralisantes et trop politicienne face à
cette volonté d'équilibre monsieur moto
j'ai
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre cher collègue
juste l'évocation d'un sujet
majeur me semble-t-il à côté duquel on a
tendance à passer celui des paradis
fiscaux de ce qu'il représente en termes
de richesse détournée
détournée à la fois des entreprises et
qui pourraient effectivement contribuer
à leur compétitivité
améliorer et et détourner aussi des
territoires des besoins des territoires
en matière de de développement
économique
de réponse aussi à caractère social en
direction des populations les plus les
plus en difficulté voilà je serai pas
plus long je vous renvoie à l'actualité
un ouvrage qui vient de sortir de la
part du de quelqu'un qui connaît quand
même très très bien le sujet le juge
ancien juge voilà merci Monsieur maison
la présidente bien sûr moi je voterai
l'amendement certains
ont tendance à considérer et appréhender
les communes les collectivités
territoriales comme uniquement des
centres de coûts
et tout naturellement lorsqu'il faut
faire les économies lorsqu'il faut
alléger la charge chez verset centre de
coûts puisqu'il coûte qu'il faut se
diriger moi je considère avec mes
collègues que les collectivités
territoriales sont également des acteurs
économiques qu'il faut protéger parce
qu'elles ont été suffisamment
maltraitées sur les 10 12 dernières
années et donc cette
disposition qui n'est pas mûr le centre
est bien et précipité voilà la raison
pour laquelle moi j'appelle je vous
appelle les à montrer l'amendement du
groupe centriste
chers collègues comme le président de
laele a dit tout à l'heure le groupe de
l'Union centriste est tout à fait
favorable à la baisse la suppression des
impôts dans notre pays en tout cas à la
baisse des impôts mais il y a des
questions de temporalité pour tout cela
parce que comme il a aussi évoqué nous
sommes nous particulièrement préoccupés
par l'état des finances publiques
c'est-à-dire d'une part la volonté de
maîtrise des déficits de façon à ce que
nous ne portions pas sur les générations
futures la responsabilité de financer
l'action publique donc il est important
que nous éveillons et c'est le sens d'un
certain nombre d'amendements que nous
avons proposé bien sûr entendu dans ce
projet de loi de finance et le sens
d'assatome d'amendement que nous avons
aussi déposé c'est d'essayer d'obtenir
des recettes supplémentaires et il est
dommages il est regrettable que cela
n'est pas été le cas je pense notamment
à la question de la taxe sur les super
profits qui auraient permis notamment de
réduire le déficit de façon ponctuelle
et certainement d'aborder ce débat sur
la suppression de la CVU de façon
différente puisque on aurait pu dès lors
dégagé quelques moyens qui auraient
peut-être permis cette baisse des
charges des entreprises B ceci n'ayant
pas été effectué il faut que le revois
bien entendu la stratégie il utilise
souhaitable je vous le dis aussi
Monsieur le Ministre un très clairement
puisque nous sommes au mois de novembre
au moment on aurait dû la payer ne pas
supprimer la contribution à
l'audiovisuel public tout simplement
parce que ça permettait ça aussi
peut-être de financer la suppression de
la CVAE mais l'empressement fut-elle que
cela a été fait de façon extrêmement
regrettable donc on peut pas la fois
baisser les recettes augmenter les
dépenses c'est pas possible donc il faut
que l'on ait de la responsabilité là tu
es j'espère que les groupes
vont respecter le choix des signataires
qui se sont exprimés à travers les
différents amendements qui sont
présentés ici
merci bien s'il n'y a plus de demandes
d'explication de votre je vais te mettre
dans donner la parole au président au
rapporteur général et au ministre
oui on est quand même toujours un peu
dans l'explication de votre mais et dans
la réponse mais je voulais revenir sur
deux points je les ai notés pour être
sûr de pas les oublier d'abord
cet argument un peu enfantin je dois le
dire qui consiste à dire notre regardez
la comparaison France Allemagne etc
voilà comme par exemple français
allemand il faut la regarder aujourd'hui
elle est pas toujours si négative que
l'on croit sur l'ensemble des sujets
industriels alors
on nous a d'abord dit les taux il faut
baisser les taux j'ai été favorable je
l'ai rappelé l'autre jour des favorable
à l'époque à une courbe de baisse des
taux et elle a été mise en œuvre parce
ceux qui sont arrivés en Suisse sans
difficulté nous avons été plutôt
favorable à cette baisse les impôts de
production alors ça c'est terminé si je
puis dire c'est ça marche pas espèce de
silo tout d'un coup on parle plus des
taux bon on était à 25%, ça va et en
plus la règle internationale de l'OCDE
qu'on verra peut-être un jour on verra
si elle est là donc c'est fait alors
maintenant on prend une autre on attaque
un deuxième pilier alors les impôts de
production personne savait trop ce que
c'était d'ailleurs la définition est
incroyable un mélange de tout il y a de
tout dans les impôts de production ça
vraiment c'est très curieux et
maintenant on nous dit ben là on est en
étau dessus donc il faut et on oublie je
l'ai dit l'autre jour on oublie toutes
les recettes
c'est à dire toutes les aides à
l’industrie alors là les aides à
l'industrie on a le chiffre alors on a
le chiffre de Darmanin l'excuse quand il
était ministre qui est le chiffrer à
l'époque à 150 milliards d'euros en août
c'est j'ai retrouvé ses propos et
maintenant on a une étude qui alors que
peut toujours être contestée à 10
milliards de reprise 180 milliards
d'euros c'est à dire 8% du PIB et bien
moi j'attendrai voyez pour prendre une
décision sur la ciae j'attendrai d'avoir
une comparaison internationale globale
et là je suis sûr que sur lui pour s'en
dupe c'est à dire de ressources données
aux industries on doit être aussi
champion du monde oui et donc on ne
tient pas compte en fait pourquoi tout
aussi
on avait un taux
un taux sur les entreprises trop élevées
un taux sur les impôts de production
trop élevés et donc on le rattrapé et on
supprime pas les niches on les garde
moi je suis pour prendre la décision
quand on aura une vision complète du
système deuxième sujet je reviens sur
Suppression report que le sujet ici
entre nous en gros suppression report
vous avez évoqué tous les sujets qui
montrent qu'il faut pas reporter je vais
y aller très simplement et ceux qui
l'ont fait sont ceux qui ont soutenu le
report vous avez dit dans les réformes
passées
dans les réformes passées ça c'est mal
passé on n'avait pas eu de visibilité et
au final ça s'est mal passé mais
pourquoi ça s'est mal passé elle est
parce qu'on disait on va le voter et on
se donne un nom pour trouver la solution
et bien c'est exactement la même chose
aujourd'hui
ce débat on l'a eu sur et je prends un
exemple qui est pas bon pour mes
couleurs sur la taxe professionnelle
suppression en attaque professionnelle
remplacement cfecl ça trois ans de mise
au point 3 ans de mise au point ça
revient devant l'hémicycle pour ajuster
en catastrophe parce qu'il y avait des
effets de bord que personne n'avait vu
sur sur le le l'attaque l'attaque
d'habitation même combat effet de bord
on revient mais si on commence par voter
mais après comment on négocie
comment on négocie vous pouvez pas dire
je m'inquiète pour et dire ben écoutez
c'est gravé dans le marbre pour l'an
prochain et on prendra on prendra la
décision qui sortira mais il faut avoir
de la confiance moi j'appelle ça de la
naïveté de la naïveté d'ailleurs c'est
très simple j'ai fait un débat et j'en
conclu par là madame la Présidente j'ai
fait un débat avec des représentants
d'intercommunalités de France
ils avaient tous raison et il disait
tous le contraire des autres ils avaient
tous raison parce que ils pensaient tous
sur la base de ce qui avait sur la table
qu'ils allaient être gagnant tous
ça me rappelle le débat qu'on a déjà eu
dans le passé sur la TH tout se gagnant
et puis quand le truc arrive il y a des
gagnants il est perdant et il y en a qui
pleure rien qui rit comme les autres bon
arrêtons d'être naïf la seule façon moi
j'admets parfaitement qu'on dise on est
pour la suppression de la c.ae c'est pas
mon idée mais bon mais arrêtons d'être
un naïf il faut supprimer le dispositif
et éventuellement vous le remetterez
dans deux ans enfin voilà mais quand on
aura un quelque chose de précis sur la
table je ne le voterai toujours pas pour
d'autres raisons vous le savez mais au
moins je comprendrais que d'autres le
vote mais ayez le mécanisme sans le
mécanisme il faut reporter
monsieur le rapporteur général
monsieur le président
je pense que le passé nous illustre
qu'il y a eu des situations bien pires
de tout temps et sous tous les
gouvernements donc moi je vais essayer
d'être
pragmatique de tenir les positions à la
fois d'abord vis-à-vis des entreprises
et de notre économie
puis et en même temps vis-à-vis des
collectivités quel que soit leur niveau
de responsabilité puis vis-à-vis des
Français
premier sujet notre économie certes on
est au Sénat certes on est attentif aux
collectivités mais l'un ne va pas sans
l'autre on pourra imaginer tous les
dispositifs qu'on veut avoir une
politique d'attractivité territoriale de
dynamisme économique organisé industriel
petit et moyen d'entreprise si il y a
pas des signaux forts qui sont donnés
dont celui d'une baisse d'un peu de
production nous aurons de plus en plus
de difficultés première élément de
difficultés de réussite économique et
territoriale
dans un contexte où s'est invité
malheureusement la crise des énergies et
vous voyez au regard des semaines qui
passent entre avant la crise majeure qui
est une crise géopolitique Russo
ukrainienne il y avait d'abord une crise
énergétique qui aujourd'hui a pris une
ampleur tout autre et il faut à la fois
éteindre les incendies essayer de
trouver la manière de passer
cette crise le mieux possible d'abord le
temps de l'hiver et ensuite pour les
Français comme pour les entreprises
parce que les entreprises aujourd'hui
leur première préoccupation vous le
voyez et l'ensemble des organisations
économiques et professionnels et vous le
disent quel est le dispositif qui nous
permet de continuer à produire dans des
conditions les meilleurs possibles les
conditions économiques c'est-à-dire
c'est pas la question prioritaire de
supprimer la CBE et à quel jour comment
c'est d'abord cela c'est ce qui nous a
amenés ce qui m'a conduit à proposer la
clarté selon moi premièrement
on décale donc supprimer la CBA mais on
décale la prise des faits deuxième
élément de dire le dispositif et je
rejoins ce que dit le président rénal et
un centre d'entre vous il est mal ajusté
on a reçu les représentants des
associations d'élus dans l'ordre c'est
on n'est pas d'accord avec la
suppression de la CVAE telle qu'elle est
organisée on a besoin de négocier et à
l'époque c'était et puis si c'est la TVA
ben on essaiera de faire au mieux ça
n'est pas satisfaisant
donc il faut se donner du temps il y a
un principe et derrière et on l'a vu ça
déjà été expliqué il va y avoir un
amendement si évidemment on choisit de
poursuivre le débat sur ce sujet là il
va y avoir un abonnement parce que c'est
tout de même mieux d'avoir des garanties
à donner effectivement aux collectivités
parce que pour qu'elles exercent
pleinement leurs compétences c'est
collectivités notamment le bloc communal
et les régions en charge de du
développement économique et de
l'attractivité il faut évidemment il
faut éviter qu'elle se trouve en
porte-à-faux avec des compétences
qu'elle ne pourrait plus bien exercer
par des mauvaises compensations on l'a
dit j'ai entendu chat échaudé craint
l'eau froide je vous ai dit je veux pas
d'un mauvais remake de la taxe
d'habitation donc oui à la réforme oui à
des garanties de juste compensation
parce que je rappelle quand même que
cette comment dirais-je
pour pas dire tous ont adopté parce que
c'est pas tout à fait tout son adoptés à
une majorité nette cette amendement de
commission donc je sais que j'ai entendu
les signatures des uns des autres voilà
c'est ça va être notre responsabilité
c'est tout ça c'est rien que ça mais
c'est pas une petite affaire
ministre
merci madame la Présidente je vais
essayer de répondre aux différents
points sans trop allongé le débat sur
ces amendements de suppression puisque
le débat va se poursuivre sur d'autres
amendements sur différents sujets
peut-être d'abord monsieur le Président
rénal d'abord moi je veux saluer en tout
cas souligner votre votre cohérence sur
le sujet c'est vrai que vous avez une
opposition à cette réforme et à la
suppression de la CVE et vous dire que
je vous rejoins sur un point c'est
finalement
une forme de nécessité de clarté dans le
débat et dans les intentions soit on est
pour soit on est contre mais dire on est
pour la suppression de la CVAE mais pas
tout de suite et en même temps peut-être
faire un dégrèvement l'année prochaine
et enfin à la fin c'est vrai que on a le
coup pour les finances publiques sans
les fait signal sur le monde économique
et sur les investissements on maintient
un impôt fantôme pendant un an sans
pouvoir capitaliser sur le fait que on
envoie un signal de baisse pour les
entreprises donc je reconnais ce point
là et je pense que on gagnerait avoir un
débat clair
sur le sujet moi je moi je ne donne le
son à personne et je considère et je
veux considérer qu'on a tous envie que
l'emploi se développe dans notre pays et
qu'on a tous envie que l'industrie
puisse se développer dans notre pays
mais à la fin il y a des votes et des
positions qui disent si oui ou non on
souhaite soutenir l'industrie dès
l'année prochaine moi je vais vous citer
le communiqué de presse que vient de
sortir la CME donc c'est pas moi qui
parle c'est la CME le titre c'est
maintien de la CVAE les sénateurs prêts
à pénaliser les PME en 2023 point
d'interrogation leur communiquer la CPME
qui vient d'être diffusé se termine par
la CPME en appel donc à la
responsabilité des sénateurs pour qu'en
séance publique il renonce à pénaliser
les PME et qu'il ne fasse pas obstacle à
la suppression de la moitié de la CVAE
en 2023 en 2023 moi j'entends des
déclarations des uns et des autres sur
le fait que il faudrait des l'année
prochaine
plutôt investir sur le bouclier
énergétique pour les entreprises et
moins sur la suppression de la CVAE mais
nous ce qu'on dit c'est qu'on veut faire
les deux et d'ailleurs vous voyez bien
que la CPME que lui-même que les
représentants des entreprises évidemment
qu'ils soutiennent le mécanisme que nous
avons mis en place pour amortir le choc
en matière de près de l'énergie mais qui
souhaitent aussi qu'on supprime la CVE
je veux revenir sur un point qui a été
abordé par le président rénal vous avez
dit finalement à quoi ça sert d'aller
plus loin dans la baisse des impôts de
production alors que vous l'avez dit on
est redevenu le premier pays le plus
attractif pour les investissements
étrangers en Europe si on est redevenu
le pays plus attractif pour les
investissements étrangers en Europe
c'est aussi parce que les investisseurs
et les entreprises savent que notre pays
a été mis sur une trajectoire dont nous
ne souhaitons pas dévier il y a quelques
mois j'étais avec le président de la
République au sommet tchuss France c'est
à dire un sommet qui organisé chaque
année on reçoit à Versailles des grands
investisseurs des patrons de grandes
entreprises au niveau mondial pour les
convaincre de venir investir en France
ils m'ont tous dit nous on veut
continuer à investir en France et
renforcer nos investissements parce
qu'on a vu ce que vous avez annoncé on a
vu que vous souhaitez aller plus loin
encore dans la baisse des impôts de
production dès 2023 quand STMicro
annonce un réinvestissement massif à
Crolles en Isère récemment ils le font
avec un plan de financement dans lequel
ils intègrent le fait que nous allons
supprimer la CVAE donc oui on est
redevenu le premier pays et je vous
remercie de l'avoir souligné et validé
le plus attractif en matière
d'investissement étrangers mais on les
redevenus aussi monsieur le Président
parce que les investisseurs savent qu'on
est sur une trajectoire et qu'on
souhaite évidemment la poursuivre et on
peut le faire aussi je le dis en
soutenant les entreprises sur l'énergie
encore une fois je pense que notre
position on en était assez convaincu
déjà pendant la campagne présidentielle
et avant puisqu'on a commencé à baisser
les impôts de production avant sur la
question de la compétitivité en Europe
on est d'autant plus convaincus depuis
que les Américains ont sorti leur ira
une fashion réduction actes qui est
objectivement un dumping passif pour
attirer les activités industrielles
d'Europe vers les États-Unis on parle là
de montant des bas de montants on a
l'impression que c'est massif c'est
important mais de 10 milliards d'euros
les américains ils viennent de sortir
370 milliards d'euros de dépenses pour
attirer des activités industrielles
notamment européennes sur leur
territoire dont 250 milliards de dollars
de crédit d'impôts c'est ça la réalité à
laquelle on fait face et donc je pense
qu'on doit aussi montrer qu'on est
acteur et qu'on agit en faveur de la
compétitivité d'autant qu'on peut
capitaliser et là je rejoins monsieur
Bocquet et je rejoins d'autres on peut
capitaliser sur des avantages
comparatifs en matière de formation en
matière de productivité en matière
d'investissement humain pour des
investissements d'avenir je vais ensuite
revenir sur la question de la
compensation en collectivités locales
qui a beaucoup animé les débats il y a
un premier débat qu'on peut avoir c'est
est-ce que la comparaison avec la taxe
d'habitation et sur la question de
l'autonomie fiscale peut se faire avec
la CVE j'ai entendu monsieur Bacher la
différence c'est que sur la les
collectivités locales n'ont pas de
pouvoir d'auto d'ailleurs on dit souvent
que la CVAE c'est un impôt national
affecté localement une collectivité ne
décide pas du tout une collectivité
évidemment elle agit pour l'attractivité
économique de son territoire ça a un
impact sur ses recettes de sesve mais
enfin c'est quand même pas elle c'est ça
n'est pas elle aujourd'hui qui décide du
taux qu'elle va appliquer de ce que vont
payer les entreprises en CVAE ce qui est
un peu différent de la fiscalité locale
que vous avez évoquée notamment la taxe
d'habitation moi encore une fois
j'ai passé un certain temps dans les
débats qu'on a eu sur ce texte ou sur
les précédents à dire qu'il ne fallait
pas opposer l'État et les collectivités
locales n'opposons pas non plus et je
sais que c'est pas votre intention les
collectivités locales aux entreprises
j'ai entendu monsieur Bruyer qui disait
vous voulez soutenir les entreprises
mais soutenez aussi les collectivités
locales moi je pense qu'en soutenant les
entreprises on soutient les
collectivités locales parce que c'est de
l'activité économique et en soutenant
les collectivités locales on soutient
les entreprises parce qu'elles ont
besoin d'un cadre attractif évidemment
aussi pour se développer encore une fois
moi je ne ferais preuve d'aucune naïveté
et je je ne pointe du doigt personne
vous avez devant vous l'un des rares
membres du gouvernement qui est élu
local dans sa commune depuis près d'une
dizaine d'années donc encore une fois
moi je suis très lucide
non mais je suis très lucide je suis
très lucide sur ce sujet là et encore
une fois moi je serai toujours j'aurais
toujours pour objectif de défendre les
les collectivités locales sur la
compensation moi je crois profondément
que notre proposition avec la
suppression de la CVAE et le mécanisme
de compensation qu'on propose c'est du
plus pour les collectivités locales
d'abord ça répond à un des défauts
aujourd'hui de la CVE pour les
collectivités c'est la très grande
volatilité d'une année sur l'autre vos
recettes de ces VAE quand vous êtes une
collectivité évolue très fortement
l'exemple plus caricatural que je prends
souvent il est caricatural parce qu'il
est extrême mais c'est les communes qui
disposent d'un réacteur nucléaire c'est
quoi un débat dont on parle
régulièrement en ce moment la commune de
Civaux dans la Vienne ces recettes de
CVAE la CVAE collecté en 2021 c'est un
million 900000 euros parce qu'un
réacteur nucléaire qui fonctionne
2022 le réacteur est en maintenance les
recettes tombent à 53000 euros la
commune voit ses recettes de CVAE
passait d'un million 9 à 53000 euros
d'une année sur l'autre c'est un exemple
extrême mais quand vous prenez toutes
les communes je m'étais fait notamment
sortir les chiffres de Cannes par hasard
vous voyez qu'il y a une volatilité très
importante d'une année sur l'autre là
avec la compensation que l'on propose on
dit aux collectivités vous avez un
montant qui est la moyenne de ces vaux
que vous avez qui a été collecté pour
vous ces quatre dernières années il ne
pourra pas baisser il ne pourra
qu'augmenter
c'est une garantie importante qu'on
donne c'est que il n'y aura plus de
volatilité à la baisse de vos recettes
de ces VAE et je peux vous dire y
compris qu'en terme de pilotabilité des
budgets sur plusieurs années c'est quand
même un acquis je trouve important que
de pouvoir savoir qu'on contrat sur une
recette de CVAE qui en plus important
puisque ces dernières années elle a
plutôt été très dynamique et très et
très importante qui ne pourra pas
baisser elle ne pourra qu'augmenter et
elle augmentera en fonction de
l'activité économique sur votre
territoire évidemment que dans le
mécanisme de compensation qu'on propose
il reste une incitation très forte pour
les collectivités à développer
l'activité économique sur leur
territoire aujourd'hui il y a deux
critères pour affecter la CVAE selon les
collectivités le premier critère c'est
les bases de CFE pour un tiers le
deuxième critère c'est les déclarations
d'effectif pour deux tiers dans le
modèle que nous proposons
on garde le premier critère les bases de
CFE celui-là il ne bouge pas et sur le
deuxième critère on propose de
substituer la déclaration d'effectifs à
la mobilisation de donner de l'INSEE sur
le nombre d'établissements le nombre de
salariés par secteur et le nombre de
création d'entreprises sur le territoire
pourquoi parce que la déclaration
d'effectif quelle qu'elle existe
aujourd'hui un c'est une charge
administrative pour les entreprises et
on souhaiterait pouvoir aussi libérer ce
temps là pour les entreprises de ça ne
reflète pas la réalité de l'activité
économique parce que la réalité c'est
que vous avez des secteurs économiques
ou les effectifs tournent énormément si
on prend le secteur du bâtiment le
secteur de la propreté vous avez le
siège social de l'entreprise sur une
commune et vous avez des effectifs qui
vont énormément bouger et donc la
conséquence c'est quoi et le disait le
même c'est que les entreprises elles
font leur déclaration d'effectif un peu
au doigt mouillé et que vous avez
aujourd'hui des collectivités qui sont
pénalisées par ça parce qu'elles n'ont
pas forcément le siège elles ont des
effectifs mais enfin les entreprises
aujourd'hui ne calcule pas jour par jour
où sont leurs objectifs surtout dans les
secteurs que j’évoquais donc le fait de
remplacer le critère de la déclaration
d'effectifs par un critère qui mobilise
les données disponibles de l'Insee qui
sont quand même très nourris sur
l'activité économique sur les
territoires va davantage refléter
l'activité économique des différents
territoires à la fin à la fin 1 les
communes savent que leur recette de CVAE
ne baissera pas qu'elle ne pourra que
monter de elles savent qu'elles montera
grosso modo avec les mêmes critères
qu'aujourd'hui c'est à dire les bases de
CFE et l'activité économique sur les
différents territoires ça me semble être
des garanties positives encourageantes
pour avancer avec confiance pour les
collectivités locales on aura le débat
dans les amendements qui viennent sur la
compensation mais moi j'appelle vraiment
à ne pas supprimer cet article
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre je voulais pas intervenir après
monsieur le ministre mais quand même là
notre position a été largement
caricaturée ou parler de clarté et après
vous employez à caricaturer notre
position nous nous avons dit que nous
sommes clairement favorables à ce que
les entreprises ne paient plus la CVAE
après il y a les modalités ça c'est un
élément de débat mais nous sommes
clairement favorables à cette
suppression de paiement par les
entreprises la question elle est sur la
compensation il ne faut pas couper le
lien entre l'activité économique et les
décideurs territoriaux vous avez déjà
coupé le lien entre les mers et conseils
municipaux et les habitants en
supprimant la taxe d'habitation et en
renvoyant tous les équilibres municipaux
sur les propriétaires ce qui n'a aucun
sens tout ça pour des promesses
électorales de présidentielles et là on
est encore dans la même configuration le
système de compensation n'est pas clair
n'est pas établie et de toute façon pas
acceptable pour le peu qu'on en connaît
on ne peut pas faire cette réforme dans
la précipitation aussi avons-nous
proposer des amendements qui viennent
par la suite je ne voulais pas qu'on
puisse clore ce élément de débat sur la
suppression de l'article sans avoir
rappelé notre position qui quoi qu'il
vous en coûte est cohérentes
monsieur le rapporteur
vous aviez demandé la parole
je voulais la reprendre parce que
j'avoue qu'il y a j'ai au moins commis
un oubli et on l'a tous commis en tous
les cas les sénatrices et les sénateurs
sur la question de la compensation je
rappelle qu'il y a le problème de la
clause de revoyure parce que monsieur le
ministre
d'ailleurs vous ne l'avez pas révoqué je
trouve que pour le coup vous ne donnez
pas un gage de bonne volonté sur la
question de la compensation la question
de la compensation à ce stade vous
prélevez de la traiter par décret
mais enfin vous le savez on ne gouverne
pas la France par décret
et ce sujet du décret pour décider de
tout ça n'est pas encendable et surtout
on ne peut pas l'accepter
cette inacceptable c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous avons un amendement de
commission qui demande qui a été votée
par la Commission à ce que la
compensation fasse l'objet d'un dialogue
étroit et évidemment ténu pour ne pas
dire confiance avec les élus si c'est
pour comment dirais considérer que ce
sujet vous avez les traité tout seul et
quelque part vous essuyez un peu les
pieds sur le paillasson des élus les
territoires ne l'accepteront pas donc
vous donnez
ce signal il faut le donner tout de
suite pour permettre à chacune et à
chacun d'avoir le cadre complet et
validé parce que sinon je vous le dis
tout de suite vous fragilisez grandement
la position du gouvernement à l'endroit
pour ce coup et là c'est notre travail
aussi dès que l'activités locales elles
ne peuvent pas l'accepter et ne
l'accepteront pas et nous l'ont
d'ailleurs dit lors des auditions
monsieur le ministre
merci madame la Présidente elle est
importante cette question de la
territorialisation et donc je rebondis
sur ce que évoqué le rapporteur général
on a passé avec mes collègues Christophe
Béchu et Caroline cailleux plusieurs
dizaines d'heures avec les associations
d'élus justement pour travailler sur
cette question de la compensation et de
la territorialisation c'est un sujet
difficile et Monsieur Raynal l'a dit
tout à l'heure parfois évidemment entre
associations d'élus il peut y avoir des
avis divergents on peut bien le
comprendre
d'abord il y a un attachement de
l'ensemble des associations d'élus et
évidemment l'ensemble des parlementaires
et c'est aussi le cas du gouvernement à
ce qu'il y ait une territorialisation de
la dynamique de CVE là-dessus on est
tous d'accord et c'est inscrit dans le
texte dans le texte il y a écrit que
chaque année il y a une revalorisation
de la CVAE grâce à la dynamique de la
TVA qui est affecté selon les
collectivités
par la dynamique économique territoriale
ensuite effectivement sur les modalités
on renvoie à un décret pourquoi on
renvoie à un décret parce qu'on a entamé
le travail avec les associations des
lieux on va en discuter ensemble et
qu'on sait que figer quelque chose dans
la loi aujourd'hui c'est prendre le
risque que sur tel ou tel point ensuite
dans les discussions on se rend compte
avec les associations des Luc il aurait
fait fallu faire un peu différemment
mais globalement quand on a échangé avec
les associations des lieux elles nous
ont dit quoi elles nous ont dit qu'elle
voulait garder la même typologie de
modalités d'affectation et de critères
d'affectation qu'aujourd'hui 1 les bases
de CFE et ça j'ai dit on ne touche pas
on garde comme parmi les critères les
bases de CFE c'est le cas aujourd'hui
pour la CVE ça le sera demain dans la
compensation 2 sur la question des
effectifs c'est là on a eu le plus de
discussions nous on souhaite
remplacer la déclaration d'effectifs par
une autre modalité pour ce que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure à la fois
parce que c'est pas juste pour les
commune aujourd'hui et deux parce que
c'est compliqué pour les entreprises
là-dessus vous avez des associations
d'élus qui nous ont dit prenez la masse
salariale et d'autres associations
d'élus nous ont dit oui mais si vous
prenez la masse salariale vous favorisez
les communes où il y a des cols blancs
entre guillemets et moins d'autres
communes où il y a d'autres types de
salariés je vous vois qui c'est une
difficulté et donc certains nous ont dit
prenaient le versement mobilité là aussi
compliqué on n'est pas sûr que ça
reflète de manière précise moi ce que je
crois c'est que grâce au fichier Insee
on a énormément de données sur
l'activité économique dans les
territoires le répertoire des créations
d'entreprises le fichier Flores sur
lequel on a énormément de données par
commune sur le nombre de salariés sur
les secteurs sur l'activité économique
on peut mobiliser cela moi si vous
voulez qu'on inscrive dans le texte et
qu'on rajoute une phrase en disant après
les modalités seront définies par décret
et pour donner la garantie parce que
c'est ce qu'attend les associations
d'élus notamment du nombre d'entreprises
assujetti à la CFE et de et
de l'activité économique sur les
territoires répertoriés par les fichiers
de l'Insee moi j'y suis évidemment très
ouvert je crains je crains juste que si
on fiche trop les choses dans la loi on
se retrouve ensuite avec des
associations des lieux ou des communes
qui vont dire vous avez oublié tel point
précis et notamment je regarde Roger
caoutchi la question de la MGP qui est
pas évidente aujourd'hui mais évidemment
on souhaite quel que soit les modalités
fines retenues associées très
étroitement les parlementaires je pense
que ça m'a même faire l'objet d'un
groupe de travail transpartisans avec
l'ensemble des groupes pour arrêter
précisément les modalités moi c'est la
proposition que je fais aussi
très bien je vous remercie donc le
groupe CRCE et le professeur ont demandé
un scrutin public je vous rappelle que
la Commission est celui du gouvernement
sont défavorables sur les amendements 19
232 400 à 463 588 707 843 et 1327 et que
donc nous brossons un public le scrutin
est ouvert
pardon
ah il y a des retraits d'amendement
donnez-moi le numéro que l'on tiré
ok
pas d'autre
non c'est bon
le 401 et le
donc ça change pas grand chose puisque
les eaux sont identiques voilà mais
c'est noté c'est bien noté le scrutin
est ouvert c'est bon vous pouvez y aller
plus personne ne demande à voter le
scrutin est clos
votant 344 exprimé 339 pour 160 contre
179 le Sénat n'a donc pas adopté
nous passons à deux autres amendements
en faisant l'objet d'une édition commune
monsieur Bocquet monsieur voldemi pour
le 844 ils sont merci le 526
le 526 qui le défend monsieur canov vous
l'avez à la main
[Musique]
vous n'êtes pas signataire Manon mais
non vous n'êtes pas signer madame
gateletard qui est signataire Dominique
défendu quelle est la ville de la
Commission sur ces deux amendements
défendus
mais ma vie du gouvernement je mets aux
voix qui est pour Monsieur ça va le
délit
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je vous ai
écouté tout à l'heure monsieur le Miss
c'est vous qui avez relancé la
discussion
vous êtes un chat brillant en politique
et je vous le dis avec beaucoup de
sincérité je vous souhaite 9 vie 9 vie
en politique
parce que vous avez été attrapé nos
collègues mais moi je voulais vous dire
quand même
et c'est là la force et la richesse du
débat parlementaire c'est que je suis
dans l'opposition ici mais je soutiens
ce qu'a dit le rapporteur général tout à
l'heure c'est qu'on nous annonce un
décret dont on n'a pas la teneur et même
vous vous venez de nous l'expliquer j'ai
regardé la différence entre certains
départements par rapport au nombre
d'entreprises implantées monsieur le
ministre la Lozère c'est 900 entreprises
le Rhône c'est 26000 à Paris 60000 donc
les bénéficiaires les plus importants de
la réforme vont être des départements
qui sont déjà les plus attractifs et je
mets pas en cause le rattractivité les
Hauts-de-Seine les rôles le Rhône et
Paris
donc tout le débat sur l'attractivité
territoriale c'est un angle mort de la
réforme c'est le sens de notre
amendement et là franchement les plus
gros gains vont pas concerner des
territoires avec le plus d'industries
mais ceux qui comptent le plus
d'entreprises et qui compte que très peu
d'établissements industriels mais on
concentrait respectivement 890 millions
d'euros et 711 millions d'euros des
baisses d'impôts donc c'était pour vous
dire voilà l'angle mort et et le chat
brillant que vous êtes en politique de
nous vendre la question de la reconquête
et de l'ambition industrielle pour notre
pour nos territoires nos départements
franchement monsieur le ministre c'est
pas sérieux les chiffres sont la pluie
et je n'ai pas cité mon département j'ai
cité d'autres départements donc on
aurait pu avoir quand même les éléments
du décret franchement alors je comprends
c'est pas la formule mais au moins qu'on
est les termes pour savoir comment se
fait la répartition pour qui est équité
entre nos territoires merci vous voulez
utiliser une de vos neveux
non c'est pardon c'est un débat
important quand même et donc je veux
quand même répondre aux différents
points qui sont qui sont qui sont
avancés sur la territorialisation vous
avez cité l'exemple des départements
pour le coup l'ADF j'en ai parlé
plusieurs fois avec François Sauvadet et
il y a eu des échanges ensuite
techniques entre les représentants de la
DF et mon équipe eux ne souhaitent pas
non pas souhaité n'ont pas émis de
souhaits qu'il y ait une
territorialisation qui soit faite comme
ce sera le cas pour les communes et pour
les EPCI pour le coup l'ADF a souhaité
nous a dit qu'il souhaitait qu'il y ait
la fraction de TVA qui soit affectée au
département qu'elle progresse ensuite
avec avec la dynamique de la TVA mais
qu'il n'y ait pas les mêmes critères de
de
d'affectation territoriale que pour les
communes et les EPCI ensuite honnêtement
vous dites on n'a pas les précisions sur
les modalités je vous les ai donné et
grosso modo il y a quasiment aucun il y
aurait quasiment aucun changement par
rapport aux critères d'aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui il y a deux critères base de
CFE déclaration d'effectifs demain il y
aura deux critères base de CFE et
nombre de Salah nombre de salariés
création d'entreprise secteur économique
qui revient à peu près déclaration
d'effectif mais encore une fois
déclaration d'effectifs aujourd'hui les
entreprises elles-mêmes le disent elles
le font pour beaucoup au doigt mouillés
parce que leurs effectifs ils bougent et
donc encore une fois après il y a des
questions de précision technique et de
détails c'est pour ça que je pense que
c'est bien en tout cas en partie qu'il y
a un décret qui permette de d'affiner
les choses mais la proposition que je
vous ai faite c'est que le décret soit
rédigé par une mission transpartisane
parlementaire avec pourquoi pas
représentant de chaque groupe de
sénateurs peut-être quelques députés
aussi pour définir la lettre du décret
qui viendra préciser des grands
principes qui seraient dans la loi voilà
ma proposition
qui compte pardon qui s'absen n'est pas
adopté trois amendements commune le
Retailleau 1686 madame Lavarde oui je
vais être assez rapide parce que je
pense qu'on a largement il a déjà
largement été présenté mais juste pour
dire que dans les amendements qui vont
suivre c'est l'amendement qui permet
d'avoir une suppression de 50% de ces
VAE pour les entreprises dès l'année
prochaine avec un dégrèvement pour les
collectivités donc les collectivités
elles percevront en 23 la CVAE qui a été
collectée en 22 elle percevra en 24 50%
de la CVAE versée par les entreprises
plus les 50% versées par l'État en
dégrèvement et ensuite on rentre dans 20
en 25 et suivantes sur le mécanisme qui
est proposé par l'amendement du
rapporteur général le 113 qu'il a
s'inscrit dans une réforme préparée
collectivement et permettant de revenir
sur la territorialisation de la
compensation sujet qui a largement été
évoqué
monsieur le rapporteur pour le 117
effectivement le cet amendement fait
dans les explications précédentes j'en
ai expliqué à la fois l'esprit elle a
temporalité
oui un décalage dans un an pour la prise
des faits qui nous permet d'avoir un
temps de travail pour avoir les
garanties les meilleures sur le sujet
des compensations dont chacun a bien
mesuré ici
la plus haute importance pour les
collectivités et pour bâtir pour
l'avenir donc le la suppression se
ferait en deux temps ce qui permet dans
ce cas là aux collectivités
territoriales dans le temps de
négociation
avec le gouvernement et au Parlement
d'avoir de d'avoir la main ensuite je le
redis parce que le décret évidemment
n'est pas une garantie pour pour
définitive à la fois pour les
collectivités mais également monsieur le
ministre je pense que c'est bien de
considérer que le Parlement n'est pas un
endroit à contourner ou à détourner pour
arrêter un dispositif au contraire
finalement c'est le lieu où peut-être
consacré le résultat de du dialogue et
de négociation d'un accord c'est même
pas d'un compromis d'un accord entre
l'État avec les collectivités au
bénéfices d'une réduction d'impôt qui
profite également aux entreprises
lesquelles soutiennent la réussite et
l'activité économique de notre pays
attendez monsieur le ministre votre avis
sur ses amendements
[Musique]
identique à celui du rapporteur oui
c'est juste un amendement de repli du
groupe centriste pour prévoir le report
de la suppression de temps de la
alors quel est Monsieur rapporteur
j'imagine que sur l'amendement
Retailleau votre avis est défavorable
puisque vous défendez le vôtre
c'est ça
sagesse d'accord merci Monsieur le
Ministre quel est votre avis sur ces
deux amendements
merci madame la Présidente
moi je pense que les votes qui auront
lieu aujourd'hui alors évidemment la
navette parlementaire se poursuit et
évidemment on souhaitera toujours aller
au bout de ce qui a été prévu sur la
suppression de la CVAE à partir de
l'année prochaine mais il y a aussi dans
en tout cas dans la décision prendra le
Parlement une ciné une question de
signal pour les entreprises et pour les
investisseurs là vous avez trois
amendements le premier il propose de
garder un impôt fantôme l'an prochain et
puis de décaler la suppression d'un an
ça veut dire que il y aurait l'an
prochain le coût pour les finances
publiques d'une partie de la suppression
de la CVAE sans qui est le signal envoyé
ce qui est pour nous important aux
investisseurs au monde économique sur le
fait qu'on baisse sur le fait qu'on
baisse les impôts de production
c'est-à-dire que les entreprises elles
vont continuer à devoir remplir des
déclarations d'effectifs elles vont
continuer à devoir remplir des
déclarations d'impôts mais c'est l'État
qui payera à leur place une partie de la
CVAE donc ça veut dire que dans les
statistiques non mais dans les
statistiques sur les prélèvements
obligatoires qui tiennent beaucoup à
coeur à Monsieur Dominati sur les
prélèvements obligatoires en France ça
ne changera rien l'an prochain avec la
suppression de la CVAE puisque on garde
un impôt fantôme et on aura encore dans
ce qu'on affiche sur l'économie
française et sur les prélèvements
obligatoires on aura encore un message
avec un niveau d'impôts comme s'il
restait la cvve mais en fait on en
dégrèvera une partie où c'est l'État qui
la paiera à la place moi je pense c'est
important d'avoir de la clarté dans les
choix que l'on fait et en tout cas moi
j'ai de la clarté pour dire ce que
propose les amendements et les deux
autres amendements proposent de reporter
d'un an la suppression je vais pas
redire longuement ce que j'ai dit tout à
l'heure mais pour nous il nous semble
important d'y aller et d'y aller
maintenant notamment quand on voit le
risque de la compétition avec les
États-Unis qui s'accroît notamment quand
on voit l'écart qui reste aujourd'hui
entre la France l'Allemagne et la zone
euro notamment aussi quand on sait que
des entreprises qui ont fait le choix
d'investir en France cette année ou
l'année prochaine non fait avec des
plans de financement qui intégraient la
suppression de la CVAE je reprends
l'exemple STMicro à Crolles en Isère
ils viennent réinvestir en France
massivement plus d'un milliard d'euros
ils le disent on le fait parce que vous
avez une politique cohérente de baisse
d'impôts et notamment de baisse d'impôts
sur l'industrie qu'on sait qu'on va
pouvoir continuer à compter dessus pour
être compétitif et pour investir en
France donc moi je dis défavorable
évidemment à ces trois amendements très
bien monsieur Bazin
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre sur le rapporteur général je
suis très surpris monsieur le ministre
de vous entendre dire que c'est grave
que les statistiques ne fassent ne
reflètent pas les éléments politiques
que vous avez voulu porter il me semble
que ce qui est important c'est que les
entreprises retrouvent de l'oxygène et
qu'elle paye la moitié de ce qu'elles
auraient dû payer en CVAE avant ses
décisions me semble beaucoup plus
importants que les statistiques vous
allez pouvoir afficher par ailleurs et
puis je voudrais surtout expliquer
pourquoi nous sommes férocement attachés
à ce report et moi je voterai le premier
amendement de Bruno Retailleau en ce
sens c'est tout simplement parce qu'il y
a des communes qui ont investi beaucoup
d'argent pour développer l'activité
économique sur leur territoire nous
avons maintenant un niveau d'exigence
notamment environnementale considérable
donc quand vous voulez une zone
d'activité sur votre territoire d'abord
c'est 10 ou 15 années de travaux
préalables avec de très nombreuses
études et ce sont des infrastructures
coûteuses que vous devez mettre en place
et c'est comme une en face de cet
investissement elles attendent bien sûr
pour le retour sinon c'est ce sont leurs
habitants et même pas leurs habitants
comme ils disaient tout à l'heure mais
les propriétaires des biens immobiliers
de leur communes qui vont être appelés à
payer il est normal que l'activité
économique paye ses investissements
faits pour l'activité économique et le
la question de la dynamique de la CVAE
et donc essentielle et la façon dont on
va compenser cette dynamique était
essentielle et beaucoup trop floue dans
votre projet il faut absolument
stabiliser ces choses pour qu'on puisse
rassurer les communes et c'est en ce
sens que nous avons déposé ces
amendements monsieur Bruyer
merci madame la Présidente c'est assez
rare mais je vais dire mon accord avec
le mini sur un point concernant
l'amendement Retailleau vous avez raison
au fond cet amendement c'est un peu
faire semblant de ne pas supprimer tout
en supprimant donc il y a là des
contorsions parce que je ne vois aucune
garantie donnée tout à l'heure dans la
réponse du ministre qui justifie du coup
que vous ayez fait le choix malgré tout
de suppression de la CVAE ma deuxième
remarque sur cet amendement retaillau
j'entends souvent la majorité
sénatoriale dire les déficits publics
les déficits publics les déficits
publics et c'est vrai qu'au niveau de
déficit public on est je dois dire que
je ne jette pas ça d'un revers demain
mais on nous a reproché et refusé des
amendements à 5 millions à 10 millions
et là on en vaut un à 4 milliards
4 milliards d'un coup tranquillement
déficit public je me permets de rappeler
dernier point pour dire que nous
voterons l'amendement hussons nous
voterons l'amendement Husson pas du tout
de gaieté de coeur très clairement notre
combat est de ne pas supprimer la CVAE
mais dès lors que la majorité vote cette
suppression il vaut mieux qu'elle se
fasse une année plus tard plutôt qu'une
année plus tôt
monsieur le Président rénal
par rapport à l'intervention de d'Arnaud
Bazin
que que je trouve tout à fait pondéré
tout à fait juste mais la seule
difficulté c'est que quand on investit
pour une zone industrielle sauf les
choses ont changé sauf la le retour sur
investissement il se fait pas sur un an
il se fait sur cinq ans six ans enfin ça
dépend des projets donc Arnaud voisins
il faudrait en tirer la conclusion faut
reporter ça de cinq six ans faut
annoncer au maire que ils n'auront pas
de retour
et reporter tout de 5-6 ans donc vous
auriez dû voter la suppression
éventuellement reparler dans 5 ans
je vais vous faire une demande c'est que
si vous pouvez nous éviter de nous
parler de la navette encore plusieurs
fois ça sera bien parce que franchement
franchement
qu'on voit l'état du débat à l'Assemblée
nationale avec l'utilisation du 49-3 par
vos soins
avec un projet de loi qui nous est
demandé de débat dont nous des bâtons
vous avez fait vos amendements sur
mesure tout seul vous avez pris les
rejeter ceux qui vous plaisait ce que
vous avez réécrit on l'a vu dans la nuit
de samedi ou samedi vous nous dites il
fallait 7 milliards pour le bouclier
énergie faut aller à 11 milliards on se
rappelle un il était vers 2h du matin
vous avez une excellente mémoire
sûrement encore meilleur que la mienne
mais mais là voilà navette terminée quoi
voilà on arrête avec ça on fait preuve
d'esprit de responsabilité ici deuxième
chose à mes collègues Hélène alors là
moi je comprends plus rien
à longueur à longueur dehors il nous
parle à juste titre d'un sujet
extrêmement important la dette publique
et là hop à la retaille au là tout cela
il s'aligne derrière lui si j'ai bien
compris puisque là il y a d'autres
enjeux qui doivent par lever des
recettes de l'État mais ça nous on n'est
pas au courant mais on n'a pas
spécialement envie d'y être c'est que la
d'un seul coup l'État pourrait pas
assumer 4 milliards d'euros de baisse
mais alors il y a 2 milliards de baisse
sans difficulté moi je suis pas un
congrès d'un parti politique ici donc on
est ailleurs on est au Sénat et on
défend les recettes de l'État les
recettes des collectivités territoriales
et un impôt juste pour l'ensemble des
entreprises voilà c'est ça le sujet
c'est ça le sujet et il y en a pas
d'autres et donc cet amendement est un
amendement vraiment politicien
[Musique]
les contrats de confiance il m'a dit que
c'était une manière de provoquer le
dialogue alors nous on se prend au pied
de la lettre nous aussi avec cette
amendement on cherche à provoquer le
dialogue puisque on a entendu votre
besoin et on en est d'accord il faut
baisser les impôts de production c'est
ce qu'on vous propose de le faire et on
vous le propose de le faire avec un
mécanisme qui permet de rassurer les
collectivités et se donner le temps de
préparer la réforme ensuite à ceux qui
nous disent ici qu'on a pas le sens des
dépenses publiques mais enfin attendez
qu'on finance ça par 4 milliards ou 3
milliards 5 pris sur le budget général
par un dégrèvement ou en affectant une
part de TVA la part de TVA qui sera
affectée à ça elle servira pas à
financer d'autres politiques publiques
donc c'est complètement neutre par
rapport à la position proposition
initiale du gouvernement donc venez pas
nous taxer de rajouter une dépense
supplémentaire c'est faux ça fait la
même chose non je suis désolé c'est bah
c'est comptable c'est par rapport à la
suppression mais par rapport à la
version du gouvernement ça fait
exactement la même chose sur les
finances publiques pour 2023
voilà donc c'est on vous tient à
préciser les choses et c'est vraiment
une solution qui me semble acceptable
pour les entreprises et pour les
collectivités
monsieur bachel vous rappelle le
règlement sur quel article article 40 de
la Constitution
la présidence sur l'article 40 monsieur
le ministre
vous avez dit cet article aura été
refusé donc vous avez une mauvaise
maîtrise de l'article 40 et vous avez
une mauvaise maîtrise comme la rappeler
tout à l'heure Monsieur Pascal Savoye de
ce qu'elle avait de parlementaire
donc c'est un rappel au Règlement sur
les principes même de la Constitution
vos arguments ne sont pas valables merci
présidente merci monsieur carochi
très bien monsieur le ministre
j'ai pas du tout compris la référence à
l'article 40 je comprends l'article 40
je le connais mais là j'avoue que je
donnera l'occasion peut-être d'en
rééchanger dans reparler vous
m'expliquerez mais là je vois pas
pourquoi est-ce que cet article cet
amendement aurait dû tomber arctique 40
ou pas on propose on propose nous dans
le texte initial une perte de recettes
liée à la suppression de la TVA la CVAE
vous proposez de remplacer cette perte
de recettes qui est liée à la
suppression d'un impôt dans le texte par
un dégrèvement donc il y a pas de charge
en plus par rapport à ce que à ce que
bah oui par rapport à ce qu'on proposait
je ne dis pas que vous voulez que vous
êtes hostile à l'idée de priver l'état
de recettes vous avez adopté un
amendement sur la baisse des droits de
succession qui coûte à minima un
milliard 400 millions d'euros en fin de
semaine dernière un milliard 4 notamment
avec le passage de la battement de
100000 à 150 000 euros ça coûte un
milliard 4 et ensuite il y avait
d'autres dispositions donc c'est vrai
que j'entends souvent les leçons sur les
équilibres financiers vous avez adopté
un amendement et je ne parle pas de
l'amendement sur la réforme de
l'immobilier qui a été adopté par
ailleurs qu'il a coûte aussi beaucoup
d'argent mais on aura l'occasion
peut-être d'y revenir moi je voulais
vraiment pour la clarté du débat
répondre à Madame l'avarde
pardon avec
juste pour répondre à Madame l'avare moi
j'assume j'assume ce que j'ai dit
l'amendement Retailleau
l'amendement Retailleau il dit une chose
il dit l'an prochain on maintient
l'impôt mais on prive l'état d'une
partie des recettes
nous ce qu'on dit c'est oui ça va priver
l'état d'une partie des recettes mais
faisons-le en allant au bout de la
démarche et en supprimant l'impôt parce
que mine de rien et oui je vous le dis
monsieur Bazin je vous le dis les fait
signals comptent aussi en économie et
quand on a des investisseurs qui
hésitent qui regardent où est-ce qu'ils
vont allouer leurs investissements
savoir et voir de manière visible qu'il
y a des impôts qui sont supprimés et qui
baissent c'est très important donc c'est
pour ça madame lavardte que moi je
trouve que vous êtes un peu dans un
entre deux un en même temps qui n'est
pas très positif celui-là qui n'est pas
très positif celui-là parce que vous
dites vous dites on maintient l'impôt
pour les entreprises mais on fait perdre
les recettes pour l'État et ensuite il y
a les deux amendements qui proposent de
tout décaler d'un an et donc je suis
défavorable aux trois amendements
monsieur rapporteur général vous avez
parlé tout à l'heure d'impôts fantôme là
vous faites la stratégie de
l'épouvantail
honnêtement
ce que vous proposez c'est par la TVA ce
qui est proposé par cet amendement ni
plus ni moins je vais appeler ça les
vases communicants alors Monsieur le
Ministre dites-nous si vous en quoi ce
que vous proposez est différent de
l'alternative qui est proposé à
l'instant par l'amendement Retailleau
est défendu par dame Labarde madame
vermillet
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre vous parlez des fait signal
mais les fessignal c'est pas qu'en
direction des entreprises je pense qu'il
faut aussi se préoccuper de l'effet
signal en direction de nos prêteurs avec
des taux d'intérêt qui sont en train de
remonter tel qu'on le voit avec les 270
milliards qu'on doit emprunter l'année
prochaine il y a aussi le côté vertueux
de la gestion de nos dépenses publiques
et les 4 milliards et même pour moi ma
part les 8 milliards de CVA on en a
besoin dans ce budget je veux dire il
faut être sérieux aussi vis-à-vis de nos
prêteurs et cet effet social il y a
quand même pas que les entreprises qui
comptent il y a aussi le coût de notre
dette donc je regrette mais par rapport
à l'enjeu de l'équilibre budgétaire les
4 milliards qui sont sur ces amendements
on en a besoin et pour ma part on peut
pas s'en priver il y a pas que le signal
en direction des entreprises
monsieur le ministre
on m'interpelle donc je réponds
évidemment à chacune des questions qui
sont posées quelle différence entre ce
que propose le gouvernement et
l'amendement Retailleau la différence
c'est que dans ce que nous proposons on
supprime la tvae dans l'amendement de
Monsieur Retailleau on maintient la CVAE
mais on prive l'état de la moitié des
recettes c'est ça la différence et moi
je pense que on a besoin de clarté en
économie on a besoin de clarté pour
convaincre les investisseurs madame
Vermeillet je voulais répondre à votre
point aussi évidemment que l'État a
besoin de recettes pour fonctionner que
nos politiques publiques ont besoin de
recettes on est totalement d'accord sur
ce sur ce sujet là moi ce que je crois
profondément c'est que si on veut
bénéficier de recettes de manière
pérenne il faut tout faire pour
développer l'activité économique c'est
le débat qu'on avait sur la baisse de
l'impôt sur les sociétés on est passé
33% à 25% on collecte plus d'impôts sur
les sociétés depuis que le taux est à
25% qu'à l'époque où il était à 33%
parce que taxé moins un gâteau qui
grossit parce que vous le taxez moins ça
rapporte plus que de surtaxer une
assiette qui se rétrécit parce que vous
la surtaxé et donc baissez les impôts de
production c'est un investissement pour
l'économie c'est aussi un investissement
pour les finances publiques parce que ça
va dégager des recettes assez rapidement
et à long terme pour nos politiques
publiques c'est vraiment ma conviction
je vais insister sur un point
extrêmement positif à l'instant à
l'instant le FMI vient de confirmer la
prévision de croissance pour notre pays
en 2023 à 0,75 c'est une très bonne
nouvelle c'est une très bonne nouvelle
qui montre la résilience de l'économie
française j'avais entendu beaucoup de
doutes sur les prévisions qui avaient pu
être faites etc le FMI confirme à 0,75
c'est très positif pour l'économie
française ça montre qu'il y a une
résilience et je vais vous dire je pense
que le FMI en confirmant cette prévision
nettement au-dessus d'autres prévisions
qu'on avait pu entendre qui nous
mettaient parfois moins 0,4 à 0 etc ils
le font parce qu'ils savent aussi que
nous avons la détermination de continuer
à agir pour notre économie que faire
merci madame la Présidente quand même
dire que nous nous voterons pas
l'amendement du rapporteur général parce
que la question c'est pas de fondre
n'est pas de savoir si c'est cette année
ou l'année prochaine l'important c'est
de savoir si l'on maintient un impôt
comme la CVAE et donc nous voterons
contre le report l'année prochaine
plutôt que de le faire en deux temps
ensuite sur l'amendement de Monsieur
Retailleau on est sur des modalités ça a
son importance budgétaire en 2023 j'en
conviens mais enfin on est on a le choix
entre deux usines à gaz différentes sur
lesquelles nous n'avons pas forcément à
nous prononcer l'important c'est la
question de fond et enfin puisque le
ministre venait vient de parler du
rapport du FMI qui vient d'être rendu
public je pense qu'il faut aussi alerter
l'ensemble du Sénat sur le fait que le
FMI
me demande d'envoyer d'autres effets
signaux que ceux dont parlent le
ministre et le rapport du FMI il dit que
la France après avoir déboursé des
milliards pour soulager les entreprises
et les ménages de la crise énergétique
doit commencer dès 200023 à assainir ses
finances et donc je pense que vraiment
ce que nous sommes en train de voter
malheureusement puisque nous n'avons pas
voté la suppression de l'article 5 il va
aussi à l'encontre de ce de ce que
recommande de plus en plus nombreux les
économistes et les institutions
économiques mondiales c'est-à-dire de
faire d'abord attention à notre déficit
et à notre dette publique
je vous remercie il y a donc une demande
de scrutin public sur cet amendement
1686 qui est par le groupe LR et par le
groupe Union centriste je vous rappelle
que la ville de la commission est un
avis de sagesse et la vie du
gouvernement d'un avis défavorable le
scrutin est ouvert
plus personne demande à voter le scrutin
est clos
alors vote en 343 exprimé 275 pour 142
contre 133 l'amendement 16,86 et donc
adopté et fait tomber les deux suivants
et je passe la parole à Monsieur broyer
pour le 586
il est défendu madame la présence quelle
est la ville de la Commission sur cet
amendement il est retiré pardon
le 113 monsieur son
le 113 c'est il est proposé de maintenir
l'information
des collectivités locales sur les
effectifs salariés des entreprises
présents sur leur territoire j'ai
entendu ce qu'a dit le ministre mais on
pense qu'il faut le garder c'est de
donner on en a encore un peu besoin
monsieur le ministre
défavorable défavorable je mets au poste
à maman de la commission qui est pour
qui contre qui s'abstient il est adopté
ensuite nous avons deux amendements
rédactionnels de la commission si vous
n'y voyez pas d'inconvénient 3 même le
troisième aussi
je préside monsieur rapporteur le 114 et
le 115 deux amendements rédactionnels de
la commission si Monsieur le Ministre
n'y voit pas d'inconvénient
l'assemblée non plus ils sont donc
adoptés nous avons ensuite un 17 12
qui est aussi un amendement réactionnel
et de coordination monsieur le ministre
toujours pas de problème pas de problème
dans l'assemblée non plus il est donc
adopté deux amendements identiques le 11
60 qui le présente
monsieur Mison je crois que vous en êtes
signataire il est défendu très bien
et sur le suivant monsieur Sautarel
oui merci madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues c'est un
amendement vise à compenser pour les
emmener 2023 et suivantes les
conséquences de la suppression de la
CVAE sur les frais de gestion de la c.ae
des régions en effet une fraction des
frais de gestion relatifs à la CFE à la
CVAE et à la taxe d'habitation a été
affectée aux régions en compensation de
la dotation générale de décentralisation
dans le cadre de la refonte du
financement de la formation
professionnelle intervenue en 2014
en conséquence malgré bien que cette
dotation de 91 millions d'euros étaient
remises dans le budget 2022 les régions
perdent de bénéfices de la dynamique des
frais de gestion relatifs à la CVAE à la
CFE perçu au cours des dernières années
ainsi que l'État avait compensé en 2022
à hauteur de 107 millions dans l'article
200 la loi de finances pour 2022 par
cohérence avec le dispositif prévu en
2022 cet amendement vise ainsi à
pérenniser la dotation compensatrice
versée en 2022 pour 2023 et les années
suivantes je vous remercie
je vous remercie quelle est la vie
voilà la ville de la Commission
deux avis de retrait
avis du gouvernement même à vie
retirer monsieur retiré aussi monsieur
Husson nous avons en 11 18
rédactionnelles pas de problème du côté
du ministre sur leur rédactionnel pas de
problème du côté de l'hémicycle il est
adopté le 14 08
monsieur
Canevet je crois oui merci madame la
Présidente de Monsieur le Ministre chers
collègues nous avions adopté en 2020 et
2021 un dispositif expérimental
permettant d'encourager les dons aux
associations luttant contre les
violences domestiques c'est un sujet de
société auquel nous sommes très
sensibles aujourd'hui il y a notamment
émaillé par différents faits divers qui
expliquent que un soutien particulier
doit être apporté à tous ceux qui
apportent leur aide et leur
accompagnement sur des situations de
cette nature là et donc il est proposé
dans cet amendement de prolonger ce
dispositif expérimental jusqu'en 2024
pendant encore deux ans c'est-à-dire de
bénéficier d'un taux de déduction
fiscale qui soit de 75% de 66
merci quelle est la vie du gouvernement
sur cette amende de la Commission de la
Commission
cette une demande de retrait alors il
vient entre guillemets sans lien avec le
dispositif de la cree mais je veux
également
dire quelques mots sur le fait que il me
semble que le taux dérogatoire doit à ce
stade rester ce qu'il est il semble que
c'est au gouvernement d'agir sur ce
sujet y compris et à mon avis a commencé
par le biais des subventions qui sont
accordées aux associations et à ce stade
je voudrais rappeler que nos collègues
boqués et basins ont montré dans un
rapport que récent que le gouvernement
avait eu tendance justement à surestimer
les crédits alloués à l'égalité
homme-femme et à la lutte contre les
violences donc demande de retrait et
invitation au gouvernement à faire mieux
avec les crédits qui sont alloués
nous avons ensuite trois amendements
devenus identiques on commence par le 14
30 de Monsieur dessus
l'identique monsieur Lemoine
défendu le moment du gouvernement a été
retiré donc quelle est la ville de la
Commission sur ces deux amendements
identiques
c'est une demande de retrait je crois
que le sujet existe mais logiquement il
doit être abordé dans le travail sur les
définitions de la des modalités du fond
de territoire réalisation de la CPE ça
me paraît évident raison pour laquelle
je demande le retrait monsieur le
ministre
c'est un avis favorable puisque cet
amendement rédactionnel vise à attirer
les conséquences de la spécificité
fiscale du statut de la métropole de
Lyon qui est à la fois les
caractéristiques d'un EPCI et d'un
département et à ce titre elle perçoit
deux parts distinctes de CVAE et doit
donc se voir attribuer des fractions de
TVA relevant de dispositif propre aux
deux collectivités et en conséquence
cette amendement modifie la rédaction
l'article 5 pour assurer la compensation
intégrale pour la métropole de Lyon de
la perte de ses recettes de CVAE
ok merci Monsieur ministre je vais donc
mettre au voie
avant demande de retrait de la
Commission et à favorable du
gouvernement qui est pour
qui contre
on recommence qui est pour
qui est contre
je sais ce que vous avez pas
assis debout qui est pour
17 18 19 20
merci pour vous asseoir les pours
maintenant c'est les contre qui vont se
lever
égalité il n'est donc pas adopté
quatre amendements identiques on
commence par vous monsieur Canevet pour
le 205
Lévy qui vise à sécuriser les fractions
de TVA qui vont être apportées aux
collectivités encore passation de la
suppression de la CVAE lorsqu'il y a un
des modifications de taux ou d'assiettes
identique monsieur blanc non monsieur
qui monsieur blanc
défendu merci ensuite monsieur plat
défendu
et ensuite monsieur le Président Roquier
défendu avis de la commission
rentrée avis du gouvernement mais ma vie
je mets aux voix double demande de
retrait qui est pour
qui pour OK
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté
quatre amendements identiques le 204
monsieur canev
oui toujours un amendement de Monsieur
Levy madame la Présidente qui vise à ce
que comme en 2020 et 2021 les
compensations de ces VAE tiennent compte
de l'inflation
merci Monsieur blanc défendu
monsieur plat défendu monsieur le
Président Roquier défendu avis de la
commission
avis du gouvernement même avis je mets
aux voix d'où la vie défavorable qui est
pour
de
qui est contre
ils ne sont pas adoptés le 119 mission
importante en général
c'est ce n'est pas un rédactionnel allez
je l'ai évoqué tout à l'heure c'est
celui qui prévoit une clause de moyeu de
la compensation de la suppression de la
cbae pour les collectivités et que ce
soit fait devant le Parlement
quelle est la vie de la gouvernement
pardon
oui moi je redis que les grands
principes pour la territorialisation
c'est le maintien en fait de des
critères actuels base de CFE et effectif
via d'autres leviers qui sont moins
lourds pour les entreprises qu'ensuite
pour les modalités parfaitement affinées
je pense que c'est bien de renvoyer à du
réglementaire mais puisque vous avez de
toute façon décalé d'un an on aura
j'imagine l'occasion d'y revenir si
c'est ça qui se trouvait validé à la fin
mais comme je ne le souhaite pas vie
défavorable mais au moins l'amendement
franchement madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre le gouvernement à
l'arme absolu du 49-3 mais quand même
quand vous venez devant le Parlement et
que vous êtes là devant la Chambre des
collectivités locales c'est quand même
relativement important si même imaginer
que le gouvernement accepte le cas
échéant on vous dit pas que vous allez
le retenir au bout puisque vous avez le
49-3 mais quand même dans le cadre du
débat imaginez que même une clause de
revoyure c'est trop pour vous et vous ne
pouvez même pas dire sagesse là-dessus
sincèrement en quoi il y a un lien un
débat une discussion entre le Parlement
et le gouvernement ne restez pas figé
sur vos positions de départ sur tout
vous pouvez vous pouvez même faire un
petit geste à l'égard du Parlement et
accepter l'idée qu'on puisse se revoir
qu'on puisse rediscuter une fois les
premiers éléments de bilan mis en place
je veux dire c'est quand même pas une
demande extravagante du Parlement de
devoir être consulté au bout d'un moment
sur l'effectivité des choses là
sincèrement je trouve que c'est quand
même de la part du gouvernement
extrêmement fermé
pardon je devais donc au vois cet
amendement car si on avait dit favorable
du gouvernement qui est pour
qui contre qui s'abstient il était
adopté deux amendements identiques
monsieur Bazin merci madame le Président
Monsieur le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur général mes chers collègues
c'est un amendement qui nous est proposé
par l'Assemblée des départements de
France il demande que sur le modèle de
ce qui s'est passé pour les régions en
janvier 2021 quand leur CVAE a été
remplacé par la TVA les départements
puissent obtenir contiennent compte que
la réforme du Front national de
péréquation de la cotisation sur la
valeur ajoutée des entreprises perçues
par les départements via l'intégration
dans les produits de référence de chaque
collectivité du sol moyen